Walk slow and I'll catch up. Let's hear the stars do their talking. All right, so today we're talking about evidence-based practice and some of the problems with research, some of the things we like about it, some of the things we don't, like how research could be a little bit better. I've got a bunch of articles about that on the blog, so I'll try not to repeat myself and kind of write about those things. But I think while we probably have different experiences with kind of the Institute of Research and like the way that that affects clinical psychology, which is our expertise is just going to be around psychology generally. We all feel that the scientific method is good,
走慢点，我会追上你的。让我们听听星星在诉说些什么。好的，今天我们要讨论的是循证实践，以及研究中存在的一些问题，我们喜欢它的一些地方，不喜欢的一些地方，比如研究如何才能做得更好。我在博客上写过很多关于这方面的文章，所以我尽量不重复自己，而是写写那些内容。但我认为，虽然我们对研究机构以及它对临床心理学的影响可能有不同的体验——我们的专业领域主要围绕心理学——但我们都觉得科学方法是好的，
studying cause and effect is a helpful thing to do. But there are places where the incentive structure around research is not terribly scientific. Because if you look at incentive structures, one of the things that they do is that they reward you or punish you. And most people tend to follow those incentive structures. So if the incentive structures are, even if the rules are going a certain way,
研究因果关系是一件有益的事情。但有些地方，围绕研究的激励结构并不那么科学。因为如果你看看激励结构，它们所做的事情之一就是奖励你或惩罚你。大多数人倾向于遵循这些激励结构。所以，如果激励结构是这样，即使规则是朝着某个方向发展的，
if the incentives are pushing people in one direction, I think it's likely that most people are going to do that thing. One of the things that I've written about a lot is that for a while, and I think that this is moving in a better direction than even five years ago when Teprid opened, is that clinical psychology and academic psychology, research psychology, were kind of going in two different directions. And one of that is, one of those reasons is that, you know, clinical psychology is more likely to follow the market, what people will pay for. And then also what works in a sort of like clinical
如果激励机制在推动人们朝一个方向前进，我认为大多数人很可能会那样做。我写过很多的一点是，有一段时间——我认为现在的情况比五年前Teprid刚开业时好多了——临床心理学和学术心理学（研究心理学）似乎在朝着两个不同的方向发展。其中一个原因是，你知道，临床心理学更倾向于追随市场，即人们愿意为什么买单。还有就是，在某种临床
and embodied way, because you're in the room with somebody and you gotta get them better. Whereas academic psychology is gonna kind of cling to the biomedical model and try and make everything, even maybe things that we shouldn't be very objective and empirical, and turn them into a number in a way that I would argue that a soft science like psychiatry or psychology, you probably can't. A lot of the things that I critique are probably true if you want to study a vaccine or cancer research or which one of the antidepressants makes this pill
和具身的方式中什么有效，因为你和某人待在同一个房间里，你必须让他们好起来。而学术心理学则倾向于坚持生物医学模型，试图让一切——甚至可能是不应该变得非常客观和经验性的东西——变成一个数字。我个人认为，像精神病学或心理学这样的软科学，你可能做不到这一点。我批评的很多东西，如果你想研究疫苗、癌症研究，或者哪种抗抑郁药能让药丸
smaller, which kind of radiation makes the tumor,, not pill, germs less, which kind of like, you know, radiation makes the tumor smaller. You know, those are kind of like if this than that types of knowing. And the way that I don't know that psychology works that way. I think that it should be more centered on kind of the study of consciousness. on kind of the study of consciousness and not just what somebody comes into a room saying like I want to change but kind of like who are you what are you how deep is that it's a deeper way of knowing the self and I think that the biomedical model has kind of lost that so I'll go ahead and let James start his his thing if you have questions or anything about any of this please feel free to to email James and let him know. Maybe you're listening to this and you wanna say, oh, that was great, except it wasn't.
变小，哪种辐射能让肿瘤……不是药丸，是病菌减少，哪种辐射能让肿瘤变小，这些可能是“如果……就……”类型的知识。但我不知道心理学是否以这种方式运作。我认为它应该更多地集中在对意识的研究上，而不是仅仅关注某人走进房间说“我想改变”，而是关注“你是谁，你是什么，这有多深”。这是一种更深层次的自我认知方式，我认为生物医学模型已经失去了这一点。所以，我让詹姆斯开始他的部分。如果你对这些有任何疑问，请随时给詹姆斯发邮件告诉他。也许你听着听着想说：“哦，那太棒了，除了它其实并不棒。”
I didn't like any of it. And let me tell you what I learned in my clinical psychology when I was in class. Please email James that. Maybe Nancy Pelosi put a penny backwards at your McDonald's for you to find. James would be a great person to email about that happening to you. All those
“我不喜欢其中的任何一点。让我告诉你我在临床心理学课上学到了什么。”请给詹姆斯发邮件。也许南希·佩洛西在麦当劳给你留了一枚反向的硬币让你发现。詹姆斯会是收到这类邮件的绝佳人选。所有那些
emails that normally I get. Yeah, I'll fill them. That's okay. All right. Yeah. Well, I'm gonna start off. Anybody do that hack in college where you you could you ran into a paywall with a any type of article or anything like that doing research? You're like, crap, my university, academic setting, like, doesn't pay for that subscription to that journal. And so you're like, how do I get around it? You just like you skirt by just reading the abstract and using that as kind of your reference point and still referencing. I did that in undergrad a good bit. It took me till like, graduate school to kind of say,
我通常收到的邮件。是的，我会处理的。没关系。好的。好吧，我要开始了。大学里有人做过那种破解吗？就是你在做研究时遇到了任何类型文章的付费墙？你会想：“该死，我的大学、学术环境没有支付那本期刊的订阅费。”所以你会想：“我该怎么绕过它？”你只是通过阅读摘要并将其作为参考点来勉强应付，然后继续引用。我在本科时经常这样做。直到研究生院我才意识到，
oh, I need to have access to these full articles. Oh, wow. And. That's OK. For me, I certainly had access to the robust research in my undergrad and through grad school and was required to pull the whole article. And we had access to all the massive
“哦，我需要获得这些完整文章的权限。”哦，哇。没关系。对我来说，我在本科和研究生期间确实有机会接触到扎实的研究，并且被要求获取整篇文章。我们有权访问所有庞大的
databases all the but you have to be a person who's going to the institute the catches here is that you have to be a person who's going to the institution or like working there in order to be able to access this stuff like you can't get a membership at a at a like an educational institution library like if i call like the call call our local colleges in town or whatever, you can't get a membership at those institutions. So you can go to University of Alabama at Birmingham and go into their library physically and sit there and go through, but you can't,
数据库。但你必须是一个去机构的人。这里的陷阱在于，你必须是那个机构的人，或者在那里工作，才能访问这些东西。就像你不能在教育机构图书馆办理会员一样——如果我打电话给当地的大学，你无法在这些机构获得会员资格。所以你可以去阿拉巴马大学伯明翰分校，亲自走进他们的图书馆坐在那里查阅，但你不能……
there's no other way to do it besides to access all that stuff through these subscriptions that cost these institutions thousands and thousands, I mean, I don't know how much they pay for all this stuff. But yeah, but nobody else. But then the, yeah, how much you said? I think that it's like $600 a quarter for an individual
除了通过这些机构支付数千美元订阅费来访问所有这些内容之外，别无他法。我不知道他们为这些东西支付了多少钱。但是，是的，没有其他人……但是，你刚才说多少钱？我认为个人每季度大约是600美元，
and then organizations get a break, but it's a chunk. Yeah. And then we have this thing of like the average everyone in the peanut gallery is suddenly aware of something called peer review and that we need to be using robust source and sources and but they don't have the you have to have gone through like a background of science to even understand like what we're talking about when we're talking about peer review what we're talking about when we're talking about peer review, what we're talking about when we're talking about robust research. It's not just like a what like a, I don't know, WebMD, like page or you know, there, there are plenty of there's plenty of like research that you can find via Google. That's not like peer reviewed researchviewed research. It might look like research, or it calls itself research. And people, you know, people like kind of reference these things. But in reality, like, there's this huge
组织会有优惠，但也是一笔不小的数目。是的。然后我们有这样一个情况：围观群众中的每个人突然都知道了所谓的“同行评审”，我们需要使用扎实的来源，但他们没有背景，甚至无法理解我们在谈论同行评审、扎实研究时指的是什么。这不仅仅是一个，我不知道，WebMD页面，或者你知道，通过谷歌可以找到很多研究。那不是同行评审的研究。它看起来像研究，或者自称为研究。人们引用这些东西。但实际上，存在着巨大的
gatekeeping thing that happens where most people are not allowed to act, not given access to whatever the, like the cusp of science is giving us. It has to be filtered through other people's sources, like people who might write books on this stuff or reporters who don't have the academic background to understand what they're reading in terms of research. So, you know, we're getting most, the average person is getting the news of like what science is doing through the public media. The public media has not gone to school
把关机制，大多数人不允许访问，或者无法获得科学前沿的成果。它必须通过其他人的来源进行过滤，比如写这些书的人，或者没有学术背景、无法理解他们所读研究内容的记者。所以，普通人通过公共媒体获取科学进展的新闻。公共媒体没有受过学校教育，
and trained in how to read these things because it's complicated. Like what needs to be there? What constitutes a good study? When is, when do you need like a participant, you know, level at certain, you know, when does it need to be thousands of people? When is it appropriate for it to be 15 people? Because there's all kinds of ways of doing research that are like statistically sound, but there's so much knowledge that has to go into that and in order to like be able to interpret it. And so we have people who work at you know all of these very respected institutions like you know like the New York Times or anything like that, but even the best like most expert people in there are not like at the pinnacle of whatever the,
也没有受过如何阅读这些东西的训练，因为这很复杂。什么需要包含在内？什么构成了一项好的研究？什么时候需要一定数量的参与者？什么时候需要数千人？什么时候15个人是合适的？因为有各种各样的研究方法在统计学上是合理的，但要能够解释它们，需要大量的知识。所以我们有在那些受人尊敬的机构工作的人，比如《纽约时报》之类的，但即使是那里最专家的人，也不是处于……
you know, the newest like physics research, like people in that field barely understood it, might understand it at that outset, much less like the person who's trying to report on it, who like has to catch on that there even is something so, you know, groundbreaking, and then tries to report on it from like, nobody understands it yet. And so same with, you know, that's, and with psychology, that's kind of, that's kind of what we get. And so it's like these practices,
你知道，最新的物理学研究的巅峰。该领域的人在最初可能都很难理解，更不用说试图报道它的记者了，他们甚至得先意识到有这样突破性的东西，然后试图从一个没人理解的角度去报道。心理学也是如此，这就是我们所得到的。所以，这些做法……
like when I started my practice back in, in like, or started practicing in 2010 or something, it was like EMDR was, like that was like woo woo, like nobody did it. But then in graduate school, you know, we were learning like that had to be an extra thing to that you trained in. But in my in my education, I was turned on to that as being like, Oh, my gosh, this is this is this is huge. But that's 15 years ago, and it had been around for a few years before that.
比如我在2010年左右开始执业时，EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）被认为是“伪科学”，没人做。但在研究生院，我们学习到这必须是一项额外的培训。但在我的教育中，我接触到它时觉得：“天哪，这太重要了。”但那是15年前的事了，而且在那之前它已经存在几年了。
So it feels like everybody's just now catching on to EMDR as being this thing. And now those of us who have been, and now for me, I'm like, okay, no, but like brain spotting, let's like divert and kind of like move this. But people are just catching on to EMDR being kind of a standard model of care, even
所以感觉每个人现在才刚刚开始意识到EMDR是一项标准护理模型，尽管
though the vet has been saying it's the first, the best treatment of trauma that there is for years and years. The public is just now catching on. So there's just this lag. I just talked a lot. Sorry. Two of those points are really important, Alice. And one of them is the bigger the study, the bigger the readership is going to be the press. And the press is not really trained to read science. So one of the things that they're likely to do is take something that has a political implication or kind of a not controversial, but exciting social implication, and then take the whole study out of context
退伍军人事务部多年来一直说它是目前治疗创伤最好的方法。公众现在才刚刚意识到。所以存在这种滞后。我刚才说得太多了，抱歉。其中两点非常重要，爱丽丝。其中之一是研究规模越大，媒体的读者群就越大。而媒体并没有受过阅读科学文献的训练。所以他们很可能会做的一件事是，拿出一个具有政治含义或某种不具争议但令人兴奋的社会含义的东西，然后把整个研究断章取义，
and then write one long paper about a little clip from research. And I think, you know, as the first point you're talking about, that feedback loop is part of what makes people not trust science and feel manipulated. And also the press seem kind of slimy or controversial, because, you know, if you look at the people that are researching these huge drugs that a
然后写一篇关于研究中一小段内容的冗长文章。我认为，正如你谈到的第一点，这种反馈循环是导致人们不信任科学并感到被操纵的部分原因。而且媒体看起来也显得有些卑劣或充满争议，因为，你知道，如果你看看那些正在研究这些大量人群使用的药物的人，
ton of people are on, you know, if they start saying, Hey, it looks like this drug doesn't work very good, your doctor gave you the wrong thing or something at a national level, they're aware of the implications of that. And so they're more likely to kind of try and change science, which I don't think you should do, in order to soften the impact of that. And then when people read it, I think they feel manipulated. They feel kind of messed with. I mean, you see some of that kind of happening around COVID with Fauci and the things like Obama were saying where, I mean, it was a good idea to wear masks. But at first, like they were worried about a surplus of like, there weren't enough like, there weren't enough like there weren't
如果他们开始说：“嘿，看起来这种药物效果不太好，你的医生给你开了错误的药”，或者在国家层面上，他们意识到其中的影响。所以他们更有可能试图改变科学——我不认为你应该这样做——以减轻影响。当人们读到这些时，我认为他们感到被操纵了。他们感到被愚弄了。我的意思是，你在新冠疫情期间看到了一些类似的情况，福奇和奥巴马所说的话，我的意思是，戴口罩是个好主意。但起初，他们担心口罩供应过剩，没有足够的……
enough equipment so they kind of downplayed how much non-professionals needed masks and then had to walk it back and I think if they had just said hey masks are a good thing but don't panic please leave some for the please leave some for the health care workers and then later as supply comes back or you know that they were just there were too much kind of dual intentioning there and you and you see that feedback loop of the press being afraid of how a study is going to be received, or the scientists are afraid of how the press is going to receive the study.
没有足够的设备，所以他们淡化了非专业人士对口罩的需求，后来又不得不改口。我认为如果他们只是说：“嘿，口罩是好东西，但请不要恐慌，请给医护人员留一些”，然后随着供应恢复……他们当时有太多的双重意图。你看到了媒体害怕研究如何被接收，或者科学家害怕媒体如何接收研究的反馈循环。
They start to change the wording or the way that it's released or control information, and the people feel kind of messed with. And then, like, go ahead. Go ahead there. Is that kind of what you're saying? Because that's what I hear from academic. Yeah, totally. I'm just I'm totally vibing. And
他们开始改变措辞或发布方式，或者控制信息，人们感到被愚弄了。然后，继续说吧。你是这个意思吗？因为这就是我从学术界听到的。是的，完全正确。我完全有同感。而且
yeah, and I was I think you're getting at it's like the other huge part of what I'm what I'm talking about is that is that where does the money come from? Because the research follows the money? Like, and where and where does that come from? And so all the best research is from these, like really great institutions, like I went to you, Mercer, Colorado, all the there's tons of great research, but where does the money come from? And so all the best research is from these, like really great institutions, like I went to University of Colorado, all the, there's tons of great research, but where does the money come from? You know, when I was there, it was like Coors and then who owns Coors and like, go on, go on up and
是的，我认为你触及到了问题的核心，另一个巨大的部分是钱从哪里来？因为研究跟着钱走。钱从哪里来？所有最好的研究都来自那些非常棒的机构，比如我去过的科罗拉多大学，有很多很棒的研究，但钱从哪里来？你知道，我在那里的时候，那是库尔斯（Coors）资助的，然后谁拥有库尔斯，继续往上……
that dictates like what, what is like being studied, like what might benefit what parties. And if you're going to do a PhD, like people who've done academic, you know, done, you have to, like, what you want, you can't just say, Oh, I hear people just throw away all the time saying, Oh, if I went back to school, but you have to find a very specific other professor who's being funded to do related research, and then get that person to agree to do that study with you, which is probably not going to do because it won't, it's not like a publicly, you know, it doesn't follow like the money of big pharmacy, you know, that's kind of what I'm talking about. But I mean, a big part of what I'm talking about, but I mean, a big part of what I'm talking about. But- Well, and I think there's a, like to that point, Alice, like I think that there is a perception that like Pfizer goes and writes a check because they make this antidepressant and they like want people to prove that it works. Like in the same way that like the cigarette companies put a bunch of money into like trying
这决定了什么被研究，什么可能使哪些方受益。如果你要攻读博士学位，你不能只是说……我经常听到人们随口说：“哦，如果我重回学校……”但你必须找到一位非常具体的教授，他正在获得资助进行相关研究，然后让那个人同意和你一起做这项研究，这很可能不会发生，因为它不符合大药企的资金流向。这就是我所说的。但我的意思是，这是我所谈论的很大一部分。但——嗯，我认为有一点，爱丽丝，我认为有一种看法，比如辉瑞公司去开一张支票，因为他们制造了这种抗抑郁药，他们想让人们证明它有效。就像烟草公司投入大量资金试图
to prove that cigarettes like didn't cause cancer, there was some confusion about it, like in the 70s and the 80s. And sometimes that happens and that you've got these huge organizations. But I think the majority of the corporate influence isn't even like, we're paying for this study. So, you know, cloak and dagger, like we want you to go find this outcome. It's that there's because a lot of times what pays for this is the taxpayer, like it's socialized research. But the problem is like a lot of that research pays for this is the taxpayer, like it's socialized research. But the problem is like a lot of that research is just given to
证明香烟不会致癌一样，在70年代和80年代，对此确实存在一些困惑。有时这种情况会发生，你拥有这些巨大的组织。但我认为大多数企业的影响力甚至不是“我们为这项研究买单，所以我们要你去找这个结果”。而是因为很多时候，为这些研究买单的是纳税人，这是社会化的研究。但问题是，很多研究……
these private corporations to go do things with. If I pay for something as a taxpayer, I want to own it. If I pay for something, I want it. But when you give Pfizer, when you give these specific companies money, and then they go invent a drug, they own the rights to that drug even though they didn't pay for the research to get it so you know I think a
只是交给了这些私营公司去处理。如果我作为纳税人支付了费用，我想拥有它。如果我付了钱，我就想要它。但当你给辉瑞，给这些特定公司钱，然后他们去发明一种药物，他们就拥有了该药物的权利，即使他们并没有支付研发它的研究费用。所以我认为……
lot of the thing that that is kind of more at issue than you know the the kind of secret influence in the back room it's this kind of like weird crony capitalism of like yeah the taxpayer will make them a thing but then you can charge whatever you want and then we'll try and buy it back and subsidize insurance to try and get some of the thing. And it's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Like we invented the drug. Like we gave you the money. You invented the drug with our money. Why are you the one that now owns the drug? But that's been the arrangement for a while. And that colors, that colors the way that a lot of at least psychopharm research functions. that colors the way that a lot of at least psychopharm research functions.
比幕后秘密影响更成问题的是这种奇怪的“裙带资本主义”，即纳税人帮他们制造了东西，但他们可以随意定价，然后我们还得试图买回来，并补贴保险来试图获得其中的一部分。这就像：“等等，等等，等等。是我们发明了药物。是我们给了你钱。你用我们的钱发明了药物。为什么现在拥有药物的是你？”但这种安排已经存在很久了。这影响了许多至少是精神药理学研究的运作方式。
Yeah. Yeah, I wanted to just add. So I have my doctorate from University of Alabama and have seen a lot of this up close. And there are a lot of ethical dilemmas and issues that you run into, particularly around publishing, even from a student or academic side.
是的。是的，我想补充一点。我的博士学位来自阿拉巴马大学，近距离观察过很多这种情况。你确实会遇到很多道德困境和问题，特别是在出版方面，即使是从学生或学术角度来看。
The model is so very capitalistic driven. But what's interesting to me about that is, these organizations that house, warehouse, all of these journals and the ones that you're subscribing to or paying for, either your university does, and then you get access as a student, or maybe you work for a large company, and they do research, and sometimes they have access.
这种模式非常资本主义驱动。但让我感兴趣的是，这些存储、仓储所有这些期刊的组织，以及你订阅或付费的那些期刊——要么是你的大学支付，然后你作为学生获得访问权限，或者你为大公司工作，他们做研究，有时他们有访问权限。
But for the most part, it's not access for everyday people. And then even if you can get access, it's hard to understand or to read. Even someone who's academically trained, there's so many articles that I'm like, I don't understand what this is saying or what it's doing. A lot of times too, articles aren't always written well. I think, you know, we, there's this assumption,
但大多数情况下，普通人无法访问。而且即使你能获得访问权限，也很难理解或阅读。即使是受过学术训练的人，也有很多文章让我觉得：“我不明白这在说什么或在做什么。”很多时候，文章写得也不好。我认为，你知道，我们有一种假设，
well, you're published, it's peer reviewed, so it's a really good article. It's not the case. Peer review is literally two volunteers who are academics who don't get paid to do this, we're just expected as academics to peer review is literally two volunteers who are academics who don't get paid to do this. We're just expected as academics to peer review. We peer review each other's articles blindly. We don't know who does it.
“嗯，你发表了，它是同行评审的，所以这是一篇非常好的文章。”事实并非如此。同行评审实际上是两名不拿报酬的学术志愿者，我们作为学者被期望……同行评审。我们盲审彼此的文章。我们不知道是谁做的。
And it's almost without a doubt you will get a peer review publication back and they will have two complete opposite perspectives and opinions. So as the writer, you're like, how do I satisfy these two opinions but still keep the integrity of my work? So a lot of times, papers get stripped down because that's what it's not going to get published if you don't.
毫无疑问，你会收到一份同行评审的出版物，他们会有两种完全相反的观点和意见。所以作为作者，你会想：“我该如何满足这两种意见，同时保持我工作的完整性？”所以很多时候，论文被删减了，因为如果不这样做就无法发表。
And so the academic structure of that is, again, capitalistic in nature, where you as an academic are required, if you're wanting to be tenure track, you're required publish but you do not get paid to publish you do not get paid to peer review, but you are required to do those things. publications a year for a total of 15 to 20 publications At the five-year mark when you go up for tenure, so that leaves a lot of space where people are having to Churn churn churn out these articles because they're also teaching they're also in committees
所以这种学术结构再次具有资本主义性质，如果你想走终身教职轨道，你被要求发表文章，但你发表文章没有报酬，同行评审也没有报酬，但你被要求做这些事情。在五年终身教职考核时，总共需要15到20篇出版物，这留下了很大的空间，人们不得不不断地炮制这些文章，因为他们还要教学，还要参加委员会，
They're also doing like a you know, they might have a life outside of this like there's so many other things going on but it becomes the driving factor because that's what drives kind of the the this capitalistic model for this for these publications and then the Databases are the ones that have all the funding Well to your point Haley, you know, the the quality of a journal is determined by something called impact factor for those not familiar, which is kind of what the readership and citation count is how many people are reading this and
他们还要做……你知道，他们可能还有生活之外的事情。但这成了驱动因素，因为这就是驱动这些出版物的资本主义模式。然后数据库是拥有资金的那些。嗯，说到点子上了，海莉，你知道，期刊的质量是由所谓的“影响因子”决定的，对于那些不熟悉的人来说，这就是读者群和引用计数，有多少人在阅读和
counting it. So in psychology, you know, the way that the some of this stuff functions a little bit different. And then also you're a lot of times your, your pay or the quality of your work is via do something called an H index, which is how many people are reading articles that you wrote, and then citing those articles in their research, which doesn't on its face sound like a bad system. But when you take all of the qualitative variables, and you only leave quantitative variables out of the incentive variables and you only leave quantitative variables out of the incentive structures of these institutions about who gets promoted, who gets paid the
统计它。所以在心理学中，你知道，其中一些东西的运作方式有点不同。而且很多时候，你的薪水或工作质量是通过所谓的“H指数”来衡量的，即有多少人阅读了你写的文章，并在他们的研究中引用了这些文章。这表面上听起来不是一个坏系统。但当你把所有的定性变量拿走，只在这些机构的激励结构中留下定量变量，关于谁获得晋升、谁获得最高薪水、谁被聘用——我们已经把这些公立大学变成了私营公司，我们不再给教授发工资，他们拿不到钱。这确实成本高得多。如果你看看钱去了哪里，是行政部门。他们现在基本上有这些CEO董事会。但发生的情况是，你可以打开70年代甚至80年代的心理学研究期刊，会有临床技术，有人注意到：“嘿，如果你在做
most, who gets hired, which we've kind of done as we've turned these public colleges into private corporations. And we quit paying professors, you know, they're not getting the money. It certainly costs a whole lot more. If you look at where that money's going, it's administration. They basically have these boards of CEOs now. But what happens is that you could open a research journal in psychology from the 70s, even from the 80s, and there would be clinical techniques that somebody noticed, hey, if you're doing
艾瑞克森催眠，如果你想让某人进入恍惚状态，你也许应该看看对立面，提醒他们自我的两个部分或多重性，开头说：‘你可以是一个好母亲，也可以感到疲倦。你可以爱你的孩子，也可以感到愤怒。’你知道，有人会发表一篇论文说，对立面或反义词是开启恍惚状态的好方法，这是你在房间里可以使用的东西。”如果你现在打开一本高影响因子的学术期刊，看看那些H指数高的人，他们写东西的方式就像你为了让谷歌看到而写网站一样。那是垃圾。你做了大量的信息，你做了巨大的
aerosinia hypnosis, if you want somebody to go into trance state, you should maybe look at oppos, like to remind them of both parts of self or multiplicity, start off by saying, you know, you can be a good mother and you can be tired. You can be, you know, you can love your children and you can be angry. You know, somebody would publish a paper saying that, you know, opposites or antonyms are a good way to start trans state, something that you could use in the room. If you open an academic journal now that's a high impact factor, you look at the people that have a high H index, they're like writing stuff the way you write a website when you want Google to see it. It's garbage. Like you do a ton of information, you do a giant
荟萃分析，你引用了十亿个东西，然后你会说：“嘿，当你回头控制能力和其他三个变量时，你可以推断出这17项研究的结果。”因为你想引用一切，因为你想让每个人都不得不引用你。这已经把研究变成了一种职业成就，但却毫无用处，而这正是科学本应有的目的。所以当海莉你谈到人们在热爱科学并投身科学时，基本上被激励以一种对临床心理学毫无帮助的方式写作，我认为这是一个悲哀的地方，我们把这些东西分得太开了。我不知道。
meta analysis, you cite a billion things and you're like, hey, when you go back and you control for competence and three other variables, you can extrapolate across like these 17 studies, because you want to cite everything because you want everybody to have to cite you. And it's kind of turned research into this thing that is career making, but like is not useful, which is the point of what science is supposed to be. And so when when Haley, you're talking about like the way that the way that people are basically incentivized when they love this stuff and they go into do science to write in a way that isn't helping anybody do clinical psychology better, which I think is a sad place for us to have disconnected those things so much. I don't know.
詹姆斯，你在医院也有一些这方面的经验。是的，我其实想说，我有一个朋友，伯克博士。他是一位药剂师，他不介意我谈论这个。但我最近，大约两年前，参与了一个案例研究的撰写，亲眼目睹了这个过程。我的意思是，我们看到了医院里有效的东西，我们研究了它，你知道，这以前发生过吗，
And James, you have some experience with that in the hospital too. Yeah, I was actually gonna say I had like well I got a have a buddy. Dr. Burke. He's a pharmacist that Organization He wouldn't mind me talking about this But I he let me be a part of a just a write-up just a case study write-up recently. Well about two years ago and saw this process firsthand that I well, about two years ago, and saw this process firsthand that, I mean, we saw something that worked in the hospital and we're like, we researched it, did, you know, has this happened before,
我们可以再次使用它吗，我们可以复制它吗，所有这些事情，最终变成了一个案例研究。但在完成后，我们自己审查了它，提交给几家期刊。期刊拒绝了。一家接收了我们。审查开始了。所以你会得到页面上的红字，这是最近发生的，因为我当时想：“这只是一个三页的案例研究，这是最简单的写作内容，为什么人们在指手画脚我们放进去的东西？”总之，这3到4页，我忘了最终是多少，花费了我们大约4800美元。所以我们走了基本上是“开放获取”的路线，也就是大学和大机构实际上可以打开，
can we use this again, can we replicate it, and all these things, which turned into a case study. But after, after Senate done, we, you know, we reviewed it ourselves submit it to a couple journals Journals decline Uh one picks us up. It's just like yeah the reviewing starts So you get like these get these red marks on your page You get and this is recent because I was like this is a three page just case study What are like this is the simplest thing to write? Why are people, you know dictating about what we put in here? Like, this is the simplest thing to write. Why are people, you know, dictating about what we put in here? Anyway, this 3, 3 to 4 pages, I forgot what it ended up being, cost us about $4,800 to, so we went the, with the route of basically open access, which is, you know, kind of where universities and big establishments can actually open, you know, get,
获得这个案例研究、案例报告，而不需要付费墙，除非他们属于一个可能为此付费的组织。开放获取只是意味着如果有人支付了这些期刊的订阅费，你就可以打开它，如果你在UAB工作，诸如此类。
where universities and big establishments can actually open, you know, obtain this case study, case report without having to, you know, behind a paywall, except they are part of an organization that's probably paying for it. Open access just means that if you have, if someone's paying for a subscription to these journals, you're gonna pull it up, you know, if you work at UAB, things like that.
如果你只是一个外行，你可能无法打开它，再次回到那些真正好奇并想了解不同利基事物的人身上，这是一个我稍后会讲到的关于睡眠心理学的故事。总之，我感到内疚。我记得有一封邮件链，一些教授、医生和布拉德·伯克都在说：“我们该怎么解决这个问题？我们该怎么支付所有这些钱？我们得付4800美元才能发表这个小东西。”我感到内疚。我想：“天哪，这太小了。”你开始思考这个问题。如果你在外面，你有一些
Something that you probably couldn't pull up if you're just a lay person, again, going back to, people who actually are inquisitive and want to know these things about different niche things, which is a story I'll get to in a second about sleep psychology. Anyway, so I felt guilty. I mean, I remember there's an email chain of like all these, some of the professors, doctors, and Brad Burke were just like, how are we going to settle this? How are we going to settle all this money? Like we got to pay 4800 just to get this little thing published. And I felt guilty. I was like, Oh my gosh, this is, this is, you know, so small. And you start thinking about that. Like if you're out there and you have something
不一定是开创性的，但可以被利用的东西，你需要更多的人看到它。一，你有那种随意的钱来发送你的论文吗？你知道，审查过程进行得非常好，他们说：“好的，我们接受它，你只需要付这笔钱。”就是这样，障碍就是你付这笔钱。我在想，如果我只是一个人，不在这个机构里……这实际上要从这些医生的口袋里掏钱。所以如果你是你自己，你仍然是一名治疗师，你发现了这些东西，就像过去那些老期刊一样，有人
that is like, not necessarily groundbreaking, but can be utilized and you need more people to kind of see One do you have access to that type of money just willy-nilly to send your your paper? You know the review process went really well, and they're like okay We're accepting it you just have to pay this money, and that's it like the hold-up is you paying this money I'm thinking if I was just by myself and not in this institution This was not that I mean the institution wasn't paying for it. This was actually going to come out of these doctors' pockets and things like that. So if you're your own person and you're still, you know, you're a therapist and you discover these things, just like these old journals back in the day of somebody
真正做了工作并看到了一些进展，你要付钱吗？这就是开放获取类型，你必须预先付费，因为出版公司每次有人免费获取文章时都在亏钱。这就是我在研究生院绕过的破解方法，如果我发现我在查找睡眠心理学的东西，做很多睡眠心理学研究，做所有这些事情。外面有很多奇怪的东西。但我会得到我无法访问的文章。我去的是阿拉巴马大学，这些数据库没有这些文章的访问权限，这太疯狂了。它们是非常棒且有趣的论文。我会阅读摘要，我真的很需要它。我的一个天体物理学家朋友只是说：“直接给作者发邮件。”所以我所做的就是给作者发邮件，
actually doing the work and seeing some progress, are you going to pay, that's the open access type where you do have to pay up front because again, the published the company is losing money every time somebody is just getting a free article, which is the hack that I kind of got around in in in grad school, which is if I if I found I was looking up sleep psychology stuff, doing a lot of sleep psychology, doing all these things. And it's a lot of weird stuff out there. But I would get articles that I could not have access to. And I was, I went to University of Alabama, and these databases didn't have access to these articles, which is wild. And they were great and interesting articles. I would read the abstract and like, I really need it. My buddy, who's an astrophysicist was just like, just email the, just email the writers. And so what I would do is I would just email the writers
找到他们所在的组织，在他们写文章时给他们发邮件。我会让他们把文章的PDF通过邮件发给我，这就是大期刊不想让你听到的，因为很多人对他们的工作非常兴奋，他们并不会从中赚钱，
on that, find the organization that they were at and when they wrote it and email the writers to those articles. And I would have them, they would just email, email me back the PDF of their article, which is what, you know, big, big journals don't want you to hear is that, you know, some of these, because again, a lot of these, a lot of people who are very excited about their work don't really, they're not going to make money off of it
除非是重大的东西。所以他们只是说：“是的，如果这对你有用，那就拿去吧。”我得到了很多很好的回应。我给大约10个人发了邮件，大约有7个人回复了他们的文章，他们说：“给你，请拿去！”因为我会解释：“嘿，我无法获得这个。我在阿拉巴马大学。我无法访问它。有什么办法能帮帮我吗？”他们说：“当然可以！”他们说：“请拿去！”但这太疯狂了，我必须自己做这件事。我没有访问权限。但想象一下，如果我……我的意思是，你可以做的一件事是看看那些作者，看看他们是否愿意给你他们的东西，但为什么要那样做呢？我的意思是，这是个问题。我们过去常说，如果你看看EBSCO，那是一个巨大的学术图书馆，他们最初是伯明翰的一家杂志公司。他们销售杂志，而这些杂志的一部分是……
unless it's like something big. And so they're just like, Yeah, if it's useful for you, do it. And I had a lot of great responses. What I emailed about 10 people and got about, I think, out of those 10, about 7 people responded with their articles, which like, Here, please! Because I would explain, it's like, Hey, I cannot get this. I'm, you know, at University of Alabama. I'm not able to access this. Is there a way you could help me out? And they're like, Hell yeah! You know, and they're like, Please! But that was crazy that I had to do that on my own. I didn't have access to that. But just imagine if I, I mean, that's one thing that you can do is kind of look at those writers and see if they'll be willing to, you know, give you their stuff now, but that can go why even why even like have to do that. I mean, that's the question that, you know, we since used to be that, like, if you look at like EBSCO, which is a giant academic library, they started as a magazine company in Birmingham. They sold magazines and part of those magazines were-
我对这个很着迷。但你过去必须拥有印刷机和所有这些东西。学术图书馆有一种成本主张。你谈论的很多东西都是为了支付那些学术图书馆的访问费用，我的意思是，所以对我来说，直接去获取它，
I'm fascinated by this. But you used to have to have a printing press and all of these things. And there was some sort of cost proposition for academic libraries. And a ton of what you're talking about is to pay for access for those academic libraries that, I mean, so for me to go out and just get it,
如果我付钱让你们通过Taproot获得所有这些学术访问权限，通过像Psych Info这样的大型数据库，每季度要600美元，你知道，乘以每一个。这只是针对Psych Info吗？不，那将是……或者那会是像Psych Info、Medline、EBSCO Post？
like if I paid for you guys to have academic access through Taproot to all of it, through like Psych Info, one of the big ones, like it would be $600 every quarter, you know, times each one of these. And is that just for Psych Info? No, that would be- Or would that be like Psych Info, Medline, EBSCO Post?
不，就像EBSCO。EBSCO是我定价的。所以如果我买了EBSCO……好的，但你不会得到所有的。不，你会得到……但你没有文献……你会得到大部分。
No, like EBSCO. EBSCO is what I priced basically. So like if I got EBSCO- Okay, but you wouldn't get all of them. No, you would get- But you don't get the literature- You'd get a big, it's like- You'd get a majority of them.
是的，你会得到大部分最大的心理学出版物，但不是全部。你不会得到初级期刊。但你没有物理学之类的。不，不，不。因为我在学校时，我们有权访问一切。大学。所以这就是我认为我们都应该有权访问一切的原因。嗯，特别是如果你付了钱。我的意思是，人们制造了一种“天下没有免费的午餐”之类的东西。
Yeah, you would get a big chunk of the biggest psychology publications, but not all of them. You wouldn't get the junior. But you don't have like physics. No, no, no. Because like when I was in school, like we'd have access to, you know, everything. The university. And so that's what I think we all should have access to everything. Well, especially if you pay. Well, I mean, that's the thing is like people make it create this thing of like, oh, well, there's no such thing as a free lunch or something.
但我的问题是，这些公司在做什么？如果你看看那个，世界上最大的学术出版托管公司是Elsevier，我不确定你怎么发音，他们是欧洲的。但他们赚的钱更多。他们的利润比谷歌还多，不是总收入，而是实际利润，仅仅因为他们的管理费用为零。这些公司基本上就是谷歌云端硬盘，当你把研究的PDF给他们时，他们把它托管在服务器上，然后向每个人收取800美元来阅读它。但作为一名学者，你已经放弃了对其中的任何知识产权。你支付了所有的研究费用，他们没有支付。你支付了同行评审的费用，
But my question is like, what are these companies doing? Like, if you look at that, so the biggest like the biggest like academic publishing hosting company in the world is I think Elsevier. I'm not sure how you say that they're European But they make more money. They make more profit than Google not gross But actual profit just because their their overhead is nothing Like these companies are basically Google Drive like when you to give them the PDF of your research They host it on a server and then they charge everybody $800 to read it. But what you've done as an academic is you've waived your right to any of the intellectual property in that. You've paid for all the research, they didn't pay for it. You've paid to peer review it,
或者你的同事免费做了这些，他们没有支付。然后你把它给他们，这使得你的读者群——所有我们想了解科学的人——变得微乎其微。我们一直在谈论公众的科学素养。好吧，如果他们无法访问这些东西，他们怎么能不从Facebook获取数据呢？你已经让你的读者群变成了零，因为买得起的人可能都在学校里，而大学正在支付这些天文数字的费用来访问。
or your colleagues have done that for free, they didn't pay for it. And then you give it to them, which makes your readership of all the people that we want to know about science. We're always talking about like scientific literacy in the public. Well, how are they going to, how are they going to not get their data from Facebook if they don't have access to this stuff? And you've made your readership zero because the people who can afford it are probably in school where the college is paying these astronomical fees to access
或者你的同事免费完成了这些工作，他们并没有为此付费。然后你把成果交给他们，这使得我们想要了解科学的受众群体变得极其有限。我们总是在谈论公众的科学素养，那么如果他们无法获取这些资料，他们怎么可能不从Facebook上获取数据呢？而且你让你的读者群变成了零，因为那些买得起的人可能还在学校里，而大学正在支付天文数字般的费用来获取这些资源。
it. But what is the company providing? I mean, a Google drive server, where these PDFs float there, what are they doing? Like, they're not curating it, they're not creating it, they're not collecting it. They're not really making it terribly searchable. If you've ever used an academic library, like they're not they're not user friendly. Yeah, like, why the hell is this the system? And if you had anything in there that you could have copyrighted, no, now you don't they own it. So
但是公司到底提供了什么？我的意思是，一个谷歌云端硬盘服务器，PDF文件就漂浮在那里，他们到底在做什么？他们既没有进行整理，也没有进行创作，更没有进行收集。他们甚至没有让这些内容变得真正可搜索。如果你用过学术图书馆，就会发现它们一点也不人性化。是的，为什么这竟然成了现行的系统？而且如果你在里面放了任何拥有版权的东西，不，现在你没有了，他们拥有了它。所以
the the whole proposition of will more people see it or I mean, I don't. They own it. So the whole proposition of will more people see it or I mean I don't see the benefit at all and a lot of times the research again is being paid for by the taxpayer and this is just another private company you know harvesting all this stuff and making a lot of the problems associated with research work. I think it's so hard on the on the researcher side as well because kind of like what you were saying, James, is that you can reach out to a lot of people and get that information, because they've spent all this time doing the research.
整个关于“会有更多人看到它”的提议，或者说，我不觉得。他们拥有了它。所以整个关于“会有更多人看到它”的提议，或者说，我根本看不出有什么好处。而且很多时候，研究本身是由纳税人买单的，而这只不过是另一家私营公司在收割所有这些东西，并制造了许多与研究工作相关的问题。我觉得这对研究人员来说也非常艰难，就像你刚才说的，詹姆斯，你可以联系很多人并获取那些信息，因为他们已经花费了所有时间来做这项研究。
They want people to have access to it. Like, researchers can be just as frustrated with the process, because here we've done all this work for free and no one's ever gonna read it. And we want to try, you know, we're trying to move science forward or, you know, look at different things, but it's just,
他们希望人们能够获取这些研究成果。研究人员对这个过程也会感到同样沮丧，因为我们免费完成了所有这些工作，却没人会去读它。我们想要尝试，你知道，我们试图推动科学进步，或者研究不同的事物，但它就是，
it's not accessible. And then also you're kind of stuck in the spot where you have to publish. If you do not publish, you do not get tenure. And tenure, you would get one chance. If you do not get tenure at your university, it's not like you can leave and go to another university. That's it. You get one chance your university, it's not like you can leave and go to another university. That's it.
它无法被获取。而且你还陷入了一种必须发表论文的境地。如果你不发表，你就拿不到终身教职。而终身教职，你只有一次机会。如果你在你的大学里没有拿到终身教职，你不可能离开去另一所大学。就这样。你只有一次机会，你不可能离开去另一所大学。就这样。
You get one chance your entire career to make tenure. And so it's like you have to publish all of these articles. And if you don't do that, this is not going to be your career path. And so it's really unfortunate because that's the structure. It's very capitalistic. It's very driven by profit, and it is not accessible to the general population
你整个职业生涯只有一次获得终身教职的机会。所以你必须发表所有这些文章。如果你不这样做，这就不会是你的职业道路。这真的很不幸，因为这就是体制。它是非常资本主义的，非常受利润驱动，而且普通大众根本无法获取这些研究。
or sometimes even researchers. Kind of what you were saying, Alice, where there's just, there are times where even being at a university, you hit a paywall or you still don't have access and then you have to like go to enter library loan and you request it from the librarian and then the librarian tracks it down but it's like takes all of this effort just to get access and then you get the article and you're like actually this is not really what I need. So I mean it's just there's so it is so much red tape
甚至有时连研究人员也无法获取。就像你说的，爱丽丝，有时候即使身在大学，你也会遇到付费墙，或者你仍然无法获取，然后你必须去图书馆进行馆际互借，向图书管理员申请，然后图书管理员去寻找，但这需要花费所有的精力才能获得访问权限，结果当你拿到文章时，你会发现其实这根本不是我需要的。所以，我的意思是，这里面有太多的繁文缛节。
it is so many hoops to jump through and if you if you can't jump through all those hoops it's just there's so, it is so much red tape. It is so many hoops to jump through. And if you can't jump through all those hoops, it's just not possible to do it. It's just so, so difficult. And the people who say, well, you know, I don't want to pay for this or something. I mean, to a certain extent, like you're already paying for it. I mean, the NIH and these giant like endowments for science,
有太多的障碍需要克服，如果你无法克服所有这些障碍，那根本就不可能做到。这真的太难了。那些说“我不愿意为此付费”之类的人，在某种程度上，你其实已经在为它付费了。我的意思是，美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）和这些巨大的科学捐赠基金，
they, the government provides, you know, basically re-hosting libraries for a ton of the research that is public, I mean, at a lot of expense. If something comes out later that it's not good, they'll remove it, you know, if you question the methods of some of these things. So, like, to a certain extent, the redundant infrastructure is already there.
政府提供了，你知道，基本上是为大量公共研究重新托管图书馆，我的意思是，花费了巨额资金。如果后来发现某项研究不好，他们会将其删除，你知道，如果你质疑其中一些研究的方法的话。所以，在某种程度上，冗余的基础设施已经存在了。
It's just that, you know that we like the profit motive. There's a lot of lobbyists there. And a lot of my point when I write articles about things are not that I don't like science or evidence-based practice. It's that I think you have to pick between a profit motive for corporations and science. Which one do you like more? And the people that kind of pretend that you can square both circles, I don't see that. I see those things on a collision course in a lot of places that we just don't wanna look at. And like to me, this is sort of bipartisan. I mean, you're dealing with institutions
只是因为我们喜欢利润动机。那里有很多游说者。我写文章谈论这些事情时，我的很多观点并不是我不喜欢科学或循证实践。而是我认为你必须在企业利润动机和科学之间做出选择。你更喜欢哪一个？那些假装你可以两全其美的人，我看不出来。我看到这些东西在很多我们不想去正视的地方正处于碰撞轨道上。对我来说，这在某种程度上是两党共同的问题。我的意思是，你在处理机构问题，
when you talk about research. And so when you're dealing with institutions, you're gonna get political friction because traditionally left-wingers are more likely to kind of like fetishize institutions and pretend like, well, this tradition in hierarchy is like great. Where are you picking between the institution and what it does or actual science and evidence-based practice? Because if you're avoiding problems to
当你谈论研究时。所以当你处理机构问题时，你会遇到政治摩擦，因为传统上左翼人士更有可能去神化机构，假装这种传统和等级制度是伟大的。你是要在机构和它所做的事情之间，还是在真正的科学和循证实践之间做出选择？因为如果你为了避免问题而
say, no no no I'm gonna set a good example and say that I like the you know the trappings and the cosplay of science, do you like science itself? Whereas you know I think traditionally right-wingers when it comes to institutions they're more likely to kind of have narratives of oppression and distrust institutions and feel like they're exploitive. But really, I don't think this system is working for anybody. And more scientific literacy would be a really good thing. I'm wondering if we, because Alice started talking about EMDR, could we switch maybe to talking about directly the way that the biomedical model and the kind of like objective and empirical driven research
说，“不不不，我要树立一个好榜样，说我喜欢科学的排场和角色扮演”，你真的喜欢科学本身吗？而我认为传统上右翼人士在面对机构时，他们更有可能产生压迫的叙事，不信任机构，并觉得它们是剥削性的。但说实话，我不认为这个系统对任何人有效。提高科学素养将是一件非常好的事情。我在想，因为爱丽丝开始谈论EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工），我们能不能转而直接谈论生物医学模型，以及那种客观和经验驱动的研究，
is sort of at odds with clinical practice or at the very least, you know, maybe not helpful to it. I mean, Alice was pointing out that by the time we have the randomized controlled trials that people say, okay, we can see that for these conditions, EMDR works really well. Clinically, we've moved on. Like if you had waited till
与临床实践之间是如何不一致的，或者至少，可能对它没有帮助。我的意思是，爱丽丝指出，当我们有了随机对照试验，人们说“好吧，我们可以看到对于这些情况，EMDR非常有效”时，在临床上，我们已经向前迈进了。如果你等到
1985 till now to adopt EMDR, I'm sorry, there's better stuff out there. You know, EMDR is fine. Like I'm trained in it. I don't really do it anymore, because there's more effective things that are now in the process of getting evidence based. And if you wait 20 years, that system to validate things, I don't feel like I would have helped as many people as I have, or treated as many conditions as I have. That's also, sorry, I'll say one thing.
1985年到现在才采用EMDR，抱歉，外面有更好的东西。你知道，EMDR还可以。我受过这方面的培训。但我现在不太用了，因为现在有更有效的东西正在进行循证过程。如果你等上20年，那个验证事物的系统，我觉得我不会像现在这样帮助那么多人，或者治疗那么多病症。这也是，抱歉，我再说一点。
And it's also part of the structure of being, what am I trying to say? Go ahead, Alice, I'm gonna think about it. Go back to me. I'm trying to say. Go ahead, Alice, I'm gonna think about it. Go back to me. Yeah, I think, sorry, I'm just, you put me on this spot.
这也是成为……我试图说什么？你继续，爱丽丝，我来想想。回到我这里。我试图说。你继续，爱丽丝，我来想想。回到我这里。是的，我想，抱歉，我只是，你让我陷入了困境。
Yeah, I think it's, and I think it's, it's, it's very interesting, like, because we're, because one of the things we're talking about, too, is that, like, like, just to pull it together, like, the people who are, you know, that we're talking about that don't have time to get tenure and all this stuff, it's like, those are also the people who are training the therapist and supposed to be, I mean, there are, you know, institutional, like instructors who don't have tenure, but like, the best people like are made by the university to be like, paying attention to research. And so then likewise, like in, in, you know, they are not tuned into what is actually happening, like people doing research are not tuned into what's actually happening on the ground, like feet on the ground in the field and like what everything is really, you know, how everything I
是的，我认为，而且我认为这非常有趣，因为我们正在谈论的事情之一是，为了总结一下，我们谈论的那些没有时间获得终身教职的人，他们也是培训治疗师的人，本应是……我的意思是，有一些机构讲师没有终身教职，但最好的人才是由大学培养出来的，他们应该关注研究。所以同样地，他们并不了解实际发生了什么，做研究的人并不了解实地发生了什么，在现场一线，以及一切是如何……
mean, and you can have like, I had, I had a really excellent master's program that I think did a really good job of this. But like, but it's still like within all of the confines that I'm talking about, you know, and I think in practice, it's, we kind of, yeah, we can just just like how research works. I think I hate I hate the term like ivory towers, but it kind of turns into like we kind of get into our ivory towers of. And then not recognizing like cross referencing different different modalities and things like that that can really be. modalities and things like that that can really be, it's more useful to bring in that stuff and kind of weave it together. But that's kind of where we get into like,
我的意思是，你可以拥有……我参加过一个非常出色的硕士项目，我认为它在这方面做得很好。但它仍然是在我所说的所有限制之内，你知道，我认为在实践中，我们有点……是的，我们可以就像研究工作一样。我想我讨厌“象牙塔”这个词，但它确实变成了我们陷入了自己的象牙塔。然后没有意识到交叉引用不同的模式等，这真的可以……这真的可以，引入这些东西并将它们编织在一起更有用。但这就是我们陷入……的地方，
okay, it kind of turns into an art, or you have to have like, it's like this is where our emotional sensitivity and that quotient and our discernment that we've learned from all the experience that we have makes us the best ones at being able to tell, or, you know, some of the best at being able to tell, like what's really working, what are we seeing,
好吧，它变成了一种艺术，或者你必须拥有……这就是我们的情感敏感度、商数以及我们从所有经验中学到的洞察力，使我们成为最能判断，或者说，最能判断什么真正有效，我们看到了什么的人，
things like that. But we're not, we as therapists aren't really given the chance to like report back to the team. It's like they send us off and then nobody, you know, and assume that you're doing whatever, continuing education, but even that it's just like, it's just checking a box. Like most people aren't pursuing, I don't know.
诸如此类的事情。但我们，作为治疗师，并没有真正得到机会向团队汇报。他们把我们打发走，然后没人，你知道，假设你在做任何继续教育，但即使那样也只是像勾选一个方框。大多数人并没有追求，我不知道。
Yeah, I got you. You're talking about clinical experience and clinical wisdom from seasoned professionals being a part of peer review in journals of psychology, which it largely right now isn't. And a lot of those researchers, when you meet them, they'll tell you, oh, no, I'm a practicing therapist because I work at the Student Counseling Center one day
是的，我明白了。你在谈论资深专业人士的临床经验和临床智慧，将其作为心理学期刊同行评审的一部分，而目前这在很大程度上并不是这样。当你见到那些研究人员时，他们会告诉你，哦，不，我是一名执业治疗师，因为我在学生咨询中心工作一天
a week or something. I think that's different. I think that's different than really having to go out and take anybody who comes in and treat a wide variety of conditions. And I don't think that's the same thing. And not to mention like, you know, along those lines of big CBT and what.
一周或类似的时间。我认为这不一样。我认为这与真正必须走出去，接诊任何进来的人并治疗各种各样的病症是不同的。我不认为这是一回事。更不用说，你知道，沿着大型CBT（认知行为疗法）之类的思路。
Yeah. I mean, again, I know, I mean, I worked with a lot of psychiatry residents that they, all of their classes are CBT focused and they have one guy dedicated to just nailing that, you know, into them. And it's great. But then you start talking about all these other modalities and things that, you know,
是的。我的意思是，再说一次，我知道，我曾与许多精神科住院医师一起工作，他们所有的课程都是以CBT为重点的，他们有一个专门的人负责把那个（理念）灌输给他们。这很好。但当你开始谈论所有这些其他模式和事情时，你知道，
expand. It's in the 80s. Like, it's great, great in the 70s. Like, and it's, I mean, it still is, but like, yeah, keep going. It's great. But where do you, well, it's just like, where did it begin? And then, again, and then who trained under CBT over time, and then going back to researchers who made money off, well, sorry,
扩展。它在80年代。就像，它在70年代很棒。而且，我的意思是，它现在仍然是，但就像，是的，继续。它很棒。但你在哪里，好吧，它就像，它从哪里开始的？然后，再一次，然后是谁随着时间的推移在CBT下接受培训，然后回到那些靠它赚钱的研究人员那里，好吧，抱歉，
InfoWars is coming out. A lot of people made money off these modalities, because it was something that they, I mean, I, I, obviously, we all practice CBT, if you're a therapist, to some degree, but not all the time, but you're, it's ingrained for a reason, because I think it's kind of lazy and that's just that's just my opinion. Again, and I think there's a little bit about why that is maybe James and why like research prefers CBT so much because it's where most people are going to start most people are going to start by being like, you know, do you understand that your behavior affects your emotions? Do you understand the role? that your behavior affects your emotions. Do you understand the role of things you do? I mean, most therapists are not going to leave that out. But I think to me, like you're saying, to make that all psychology is, is behavior and symptoms. And that are measurable with a number that is incredibly lazy. I was going to say it's lazy in the fact that it also doesn't, it doesn't treat the underlying trauma and the way that trauma is formed. And that's the thing that I think
InfoWars（阴谋论媒体）要出来了。很多人靠这些模式赚钱，因为这是他们……我的意思是，我，我，显然，如果你是治疗师，我们都在某种程度上实践CBT，但不是一直，但你，它根深蒂固是有原因的，因为我认为它有点懒惰，这只是我的观点。再一次，我认为关于为什么会这样，也许詹姆斯知道，为什么研究如此偏爱CBT，因为这是大多数人开始的地方，大多数人会从“你明白你的行为会影响你的情绪吗？你明白……的作用吗？”开始。你明白你的行为会影响你的情绪吗？你明白你所做事情的作用吗？我的意思是，大多数治疗师不会忽略这一点。但我认为对我来说，就像你说的，把心理学全部归结为行为和症状，并且可以用数字来衡量，这是极其懒惰的。我本来想说，它懒惰在于它也没有，它没有治疗潜在的创伤以及创伤形成的方式。这就是我认为
we're seeing a lot of now is a lot of, again, a lot of these behaviors spawn from how our brain was rewired in trauma. And, and I think the lazy aspect of it, CBT, and again, we all practice it to some degree, but it's, it's casting a net on some of these behaviors and not necessarily targeting a specific species. Just like fishing, you cast a net and you're going to grab up a billion fish, but what if you just want tuna? And tuna is trauma. And so you have to find, there's different ways of getting that tuna fish. And there a lot of you know there's a specific way of you can't really just cast net over and I think that's one reason that it works is because they saw a lot of this population it trickled down and it worked for a lot and people can change their behavior by thinking
我们现在看到很多的情况，很多，再一次，很多这些行为源于我们的大脑在创伤中是如何被重连的。而且，我认为它的懒惰方面，CBT，再一次，我们都在某种程度上实践它，但它是在这些行为上撒网，而不一定针对特定的物种。就像钓鱼，你撒网，你会抓到十亿条鱼，但如果你只想要金枪鱼呢？而金枪鱼就是创伤。所以你必须找到，有不同的方法来获得那种金枪鱼。而且有很多，你知道，有一种特定的方式，你不能真的只是撒网，我认为这就是它有效的一个原因，因为他们看到了很多人群，它流传下来，对很多人有效，人们可以通过思考来改变他们的行为
about it or changing some patterns in the behavior changes but that doesn't solve the thing the behavior or they're changing something again they're fixing the symptom and not necessarily the actual problem with it and go saying root cause or saying like emotion You avoid or saying like insight I mean all of those like, you know Certainly when you start talking about somatic energy all those are things that cannot be turned into a number for a study But patient satisfaction and patient self-reported, did I get more out of this than the other one? That can't. And we tend to not try and publish those things, because I think a lot of people do want to protect, they want to pretend that all these
或者改变行为中的一些模式，行为就会改变，但这并不能解决问题，或者他们正在改变一些东西，再一次，他们是在修复症状，而不是解决实际问题，说根本原因或说情感回避，或者说洞察力，我的意思是，所有这些，你知道，当然当你开始谈论躯体能量时，所有这些都是无法转化为研究数字的东西。但患者满意度和患者自我报告，我从这个中学到的比另一个多吗？那可以。而且我们倾向于不尝试发表这些东西，因为我认为很多人确实想保护，他们想假装所有这些
models of therapy are the same way in ways that they aren't. Like, if you look at a lot of cross comparisons where somebody did, you know, depth analytical work versus CBT in the study, they'll say, Hey, how do these 50 models of therapy treat migraine headaches or something? Well, when you look at the study, the person who's doing relational psychoanalysis or, or something that is a little bit more emotion focused, a lot of times those people are saying, oh, my gosh, I realized that this pattern goes on forever. My relationships are better and more creative. And then the researchers like, Yeah, but did
治疗模型在某些方面是相同的，但事实并非如此。如果你看看很多交叉比较，有人在研究中做了深度分析工作与CBT，他们会说，嘿，这50种治疗模型是如何治疗偏头痛之类的？好吧，当你查看研究时，做关系心理分析或某种更注重情感的人，很多时候那些人会说，哦，我的天哪，我意识到这种模式永远持续下去。我的人际关系更好，更有创造力了。然后研究人员说，是的，但是
the migraine headaches go down? And they're like, yeah, that happened too. And they're like, all right, moderately effective. And that's the raw data is that, whereas the CBT person is just saying, when I don't eat sugar, when I drink water before bed, when I exercise in the morning, my headaches went down. But the candidate in the study is telling you,
偏头痛减轻了吗？他们说，是的，那也发生了。他们说，好吧，中度有效。这就是原始数据，而CBT的人只是说，当我戒糖时，当我睡前喝水时，当我早上锻炼时，我的头痛减轻了。但研究中的候选人正在告诉你，
I got more out of this model. And the researcher's discarding it to turn that into a number to publish a paper. Yeah I think you're really hitting on this idea around quantitative versus qualitative research and quantitative research is the highest at the very top of the research tower driven by medical biomedical, and also because they can be published quickly and turned out quickly. And that's also part of the problem of why we see all these modalities taking so long,
我从这个模型中学到了更多。而研究人员却丢弃了它，将其转化为数字以发表论文。是的，我认为你真的触及了这个关于定量与定性研究的想法，定量研究处于研究塔的最顶端，由医学、生物医学驱动，也因为它们可以快速发表并快速产出。这也是为什么我们看到所有这些模式需要这么长时间的问题，
you know, to like to catch up to what's going on clinically versus research, because it takes so long to publish research. After you've done, you know, written the article and you've gone through IRB and you do your study, it takes years to get work published sometimes. So by the time it comes out, it's, you know, clinically, people have already figured a lot of that out. And so it's just very hard and qualitative study take so much more time. And you're right, you cannot quantify people's experiences in that way all the time.
你知道，去赶上临床上正在发生的事情与研究之间的差距，因为发表研究需要很长时间。在你完成了，你知道，写了文章并经过了IRB（机构审查委员会）并做了你的研究之后，有时需要几年时间才能发表工作。所以当它出来时，你知道，在临床上，人们已经弄清楚了很多。所以这非常困难，定性研究需要更多的时间。而且你是对的，你不能总是以那种方式量化人们的经历。
Qualitative research is so important and I'm a huge proponent of it for that reason because we're able to capture lived experience. We're able to get, instead of saying, did you experience one to five, what was your scale versus like, what was your actual experience? Use your own words and being able to use that. I think that often more closely aligns with clinical work because that's what we're doing.
定性研究非常重要，我非常支持它，原因就在于此，因为我们能够捕捉到生活经验。我们能够得到，而不是说，你经历了1到5，你的量表是多少，而是，你的实际经历是什么？用你自己的话，并能够使用它。我认为这通常与临床工作更紧密地结合，因为这就是我们正在做的。
We're talking to people and engaging with people and hearing their stories and their processes and how trauma is directly impacting them. So research is also not motivated to do qualitative work as much. It is completely quantitative driven and that has been the way it's been since the beginning and it's still like that now. Well, and I think that when you go back to why does that exist, I mean there's there's two things is like why do we think that way as humans and then to like why did that happen to American politics and British politics around the same time. You know, the Why Do We Do It as Humans? Theodore Porter has a really interesting book on the critique of quantification. And he goes through like human history. And he says like, why did we start to think objectively? Could you go back to the earliest writings? It's all subjective. It's all just even things that are objective now, like history are pretty subjective when when somebody is watching, you know, Vesuvius erupt, and they're like, I saw this thing, it was hot, this is what happened.
我们正在与人交谈，与人互动，倾听他们的故事和过程，以及创伤是如何直接影响他们的。所以研究也没有动力去做那么多的定性工作。它是完全由定量驱动的，从一开始就是这样，现在仍然是这样。好吧，我认为当你回到为什么它存在时，我的意思是，有两件事，一是我们作为人类为什么那样思考，然后是为什么在同一时间发生在美国政治和英国政治中。你知道，“我们为什么这样做”？西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）有一本关于量化批判的非常有趣的书。他回顾了人类历史。他说，为什么我们开始客观地思考？你能回到最早的著作吗？一切都是主观的。即使是现在客观的东西，比如历史，当有人在观看时也是相当主观的，你知道，维苏威火山爆发，他们说，我看到了这个东西，它很热，这就是发生的事情。
They're not saying, on this date, this thing, it's not objective data. So he's looking at why does that happen? There's a couple of theories and he tries to go through all the theories we have and then kind of disprove them and say that's actually not it. What it is, is when you get civilizations that get to a certain size,
他们没有说，在这一天，这个东西，这不是客观数据。所以他正在研究为什么会发生这种情况？有几种理论，他试图遍历我们所有的理论，然后试图反驳它们，说那其实不是原因。真正的原因是，当文明达到一定规模时，
people don't trust each other. And so objectivity is this way of in low trust systems trying to validate things. Like if I just go next door to James's office and I'm like, hey, I wanna buy some milk from your cow. And James is like, okay, here you go. I just kind of trust, cause I have this relationship that that milk is gonna be good milk.
人们互不信任。所以客观性是在低信任系统中试图验证事物的一种方式。如果我只是走到隔壁詹姆斯的办公室，说，嘿，我想从你的牛那里买些牛奶。詹姆斯说，好的，给你。我只是有点信任，因为我有这种关系，那牛奶会是好牛奶。
But when you get larger systems, the bronze age carving about the copper merchant is the one that like all the anthropology students are going to learn. Is this guy complaining about, you know, don't buy from Ahmed? His copper, it sucks. It's not good. It's mixed with lead. You know, it's when we need these outside organizations to come in and say, a third party has verified that this is what you're getting. It's usually around markets and it's usually around lack of trust. And what it does is it says that nothing can be self-evident. And I think that, you know, on that first point of our human need for objectivity, we should really be able to have more trust that some of these things like somatic psychology, even if we can't turn it into a perfect variable, that there's a somatic relationship to emotion, let's stop researching that.
但当你进入更大的系统时，关于铜商人的青铜时代雕刻是所有人类学学生都会学习的。这家伙在抱怨，你知道，不要从艾哈迈德那里买。他的铜，烂透了。它不好。它混有铅。你知道，当我们需要这些外部组织进来并说，第三方已经验证了这就是你得到的东西时。它通常围绕市场，通常围绕缺乏信任。它所做的是说，没有什么是不言自明的。我认为，你知道，在我们对客观性的人类需求的第一点上，我们真的应该能够对其中一些事情有更多的信任，比如躯体心理学，即使我们不能把它变成一个完美的变量，但情感与躯体之间存在关系，让我们停止研究那个。
Because I think that most people who practice things, you know, and clinically have seen that, that there are kind of somatic carriers of emotion. There's markers and a lot of neurology is looking at that. The second thing is like, the reason that CBT takes over in the 80s is because when Reagan and Thatcher come in, that's part of their promise, is that they're going to only fund things that are effective
因为我认为大多数实践这些事情的人，你知道，在临床上已经看到，情感有某种躯体载体。有标记，很多神经学正在研究那个。第二件事是，CBT在80年代接管的原因是因为当里根和撒切尔上台时，那是他们承诺的一部分，即他们将只资助有效的东西，
that tax money is not going to be wasted. So schools are going to have to prove that the kids get smarter with all this academic, with all this standardized testing. Hospitals are going to be subjected to these metrics. Well, that doesn't ever really work. When you look at the hospitals that were effective and got all that federal funding in the 80s, a lot of them were just reclassifying chairs as hospital beds to say, yeah, all the patients were in the beds.
税款不会被浪费。所以学校将不得不证明孩子们通过所有这些学术，通过所有这些标准化测试变得更聪明。医院将受到这些指标的约束。好吧，那从来没有真正起作用。当你看看80年代那些有效并获得所有联邦资助的医院时，很多只是把椅子重新归类为病床，以说，是的，所有病人都躺在床上。
Like literally, that's the thing that happened. You see those metrics getting moved around, but it doesn't actually make progress better. But you do see CBT become the preferred modality because it's something that lets you reduce everything down to a number so it can pass randomized controlled trials, which good models of psychotherapy have a subjective element that you can't turn into a number. So we don't prefer it. And that's like why that takes over, I think in a way that that is not great. And when you look at why CBT has like worse and worse returns every year,
就像字面意思，这就是发生的事情。你看到那些指标被移来移去，但它并没有真正让进步变得更好。但你确实看到CBT成为首选模式，因为它是一种让你把一切都简化为数字的东西，这样它就可以通过随机对照试验，而好的心理治疗模型有一种你无法转化为数字的主观元素。所以我们不偏爱它。这就是为什么它接管了，我认为以一种并不伟大的方式。当你看看为什么CBT每年的回报越来越差，
that clinically it's showing that this is supposed to be the best model. But then you look at patient outcomes in the real world and they actually are getting worse the more that's adopted. And that's for a couple of reasons. I mean, one is that you can do things in a lab, you can't do in a clinic. But I think more broadly, a lot of those people that were trained in CBT and said they were doing CBT, like one of my favorite providers locally, Winn-Scheps, is, you know, he says he's a CBT guy. But when you look at him and his therapy and run cases with him, he's a lot more relational and kind of psychodynamic. But those guys were learning that stuff in the water, even though they said they were
在临床上显示这应该是最好的模型。但当你看看现实世界中的患者结果时，随着它的采用，它们实际上变得更糟了。这有几个原因。我的意思是，一个是你可以做实验室里做不到的事情，你不能在诊所里做。但我认为更广泛地说，很多受过CBT培训并说他们在做CBT的人，就像我当地最喜欢的提供者之一，温·谢普斯（Winn-Scheps），是，你知道，他说他是一个CBT人。但当你看看他和他的治疗，并和他一起处理案例时，他更具关系性和心理动力学。但那些家伙在水里学到了那些东西，尽管他们说他们是
CBT practitioners. And as that stuff quit being taught in colleges, they didn't have any skills other than CBT. So you really are seeing the effect of it in a vacuum. When you have people in the 90s and the 2000s that are graduating from school, and they don't know anything about the history of thes and the 2000s that are graduating from school, and they don't know anything about the history of the profession and the way that even somebody in the 80s who says, I do CBT, they really did.
CBT从业者。随着那些东西不再在大学里教授，他们除了CBT之外没有任何技能。所以你真的在真空中看到了它的效果。当你让90年代和2000年代从学校毕业的人，他们对这个职业的历史一无所知，即使是80年代说“我做CBT”的人，他们真的做了。
They got a lot of that embodied wisdom from the 60s and 70s, just in the water of their training. So I think those are two variables that are important to kind of sit with when you're looking at how the industry moved there. Yeah. And I think too, we can kind of, you can kind of zoom out to the macro level of like the collective moved there. Yeah. And I think too, we can kind of, you can kind of zoom out to the macro level
他们从60年代和70年代获得了许多那种具身智慧，就在他们培训的水里。所以我认为这是两个变量，当你观察行业如何移动到那里时，坐下来思考是很重要的。是的。而且我认为，我们可以，你可以缩小到宏观层面，就像集体移动到那里。是的。而且我认为，我们可以，你可以缩小到宏观层面
of like the collective and everything. And it's like, that's sort of just evident or shows us like where I think it's like the common denominator or like reduction to the mean of like what the public, what the collective consciousness is able to even like process and understand. And it's like this like Cognition plus behavior is still this like touch point that's not that like science is grappling with it's like the other ivory towers
就像集体和一切。而且就像，那只是显而易见的，或者向我们展示了，我认为这就像最小公分母，或者像集体意识甚至能够处理和理解的平均值的减少。而且就像这种认知加行为仍然是科学正在努力解决的接触点，就像其他象牙塔
haven't caught up and so even psycho, you know while psychology is like 60 years down the road, or you know 50 years down the road from CBT. It's like You know where know, 50 years down the road from CBT, it's like, you know, we're, we are far beyond it. And so, but then like we're saying, there's this echo, you know, it's kind of in this vacuum. And so at the outset, when CBT was first being practiced, these were people were innovators who were doing something new. And it was on the cusp of what the collective was
还没有赶上，所以即使心理学，你知道，虽然心理学距离CBT还有60年的路程，或者你知道，距离CBT还有50年的路程。就像你知道，我们远超它了。所以，但就像我们说的，有一个回声，你知道，它有点在这个真空中。所以在一开始，当CBT首次被实践时，这些人是创新者，他们正在做一些新的事情。而且它处于集体正在
like, putting together and thinking about. But when we churn out people people 30 years later doing the same thing, it's just totally stripped of what was innovative about in the first place. And we're telling counselors, no, you need to do this exact thing in this like very neutered stripped down way from back then. And we're just taking the practitioners are the artists the practitioners are the artists are the ones who like
拼凑和思考的事情的风口浪尖。但当我们30年后 churn 出做同样事情的人时，它完全剥离了最初的创新之处。我们告诉咨询师，不，你需要以这种非常被阉割的、从那时起剥离的方式做这件确切的事情。我们只是把从业者当作艺术家，从业者是艺术家，他们是
interpret are the interpreters of the research, you know, just like lawyers are interpreters of the law. Like the, we are the, we are the interpreters and the practitioners of it, but we're being held back by like the collective, not being able, it's just like quite hasn't caught, like it just like, like it's like the neurologist and the physicists Can't really get their hands around how cognition and behavior would be connected because they can't understand consciousness
解释者，研究的解释者，你知道，就像律师是法律的解释者。就像，我们是，我们是它的解释者和从业者，但我们被集体阻碍了，无法，它只是，还没有赶上，就像，就像神经学家和物理学家无法真正掌握认知和行为是如何连接的，因为他们无法理解意识
And so it's like creates this like anchor where it's like No, the public isn't gonna let us move on from like what is this with cognition and behavior until all the other like quote-unquote Ivory towers like have caught up and start to understand what we're talking about every year. That's a fantastic point, Alice, because you're talking about re-centering psychology as a response to the environment of the world, which changes. And it's not 1988.
所以它就像创造了这个锚，就像不，公众不会让我们从认知和行为中走出来，直到所有其他所谓的象牙塔都赶上并开始理解我们每年在谈论什么。这是一个极好的观点，爱丽丝，因为你在谈论将心理学重新定位为对世界环境的回应，世界环境在变化。而且现在不是1988年。
And so to say that there's a best model of psychotherapy, we've found it. It passed a randomized controlled trial, so let's do this one forever. I mean, one, you're going to get people that are deeply curious that like hierarchies that like tradition more so than they like innovation, or maybe helping people that navigate towards a system like that. But two, it just isn't honest. It's like saying we should do Victorian, you know, education in schools, like. Yeah. I mean, so well. Big CBT took Joel out.
所以说有一种最好的心理治疗模型，我们找到了它。它通过了随机对照试验，所以让我们永远做这个。我的意思是，第一，你会得到那些深感好奇的人，他们喜欢等级制度，喜欢传统胜过喜欢创新，或者也许帮助那些倾向于这种系统的人。但第二，它就是不诚实。这就像说我们应该在学校里进行维多利亚时代的教育，就像。是的。我的意思是，所以好吧。大型CBT把乔尔带走了。
Big CBT. Yeah. No, it does feel like that. And this gets to I mean, I I I harp about that. There's like a big pyramid scheme and within the world of therapy, too, about like what you're even, you know, you can say you practice CBT coming out of school, but there are all these other modalities like EMDR, you have to pay a few more thousand dollars to get the training for to do EMDR after you've gone to school, even though in school you learn like this is like a standard thing, you know, and like we're saying that's 20 years ago, but, but, you know, you have to come out of school and then pay, you know,
大型CBT。是的。不，它确实感觉像那样。这触及了，我的意思是，我喋喋不休地谈论这个。在治疗世界里也有一个巨大的金字塔计划，关于你甚至，你知道，你可以说你从学校出来实践CBT，但还有所有这些其他模式，比如EMDR，你必须多付几千美元才能获得培训来做EMDR，即使在学校里你学到这就像是一个标准的东西，你知道，就像我们说的那是20年前的事了，但是，但是，你知道，你必须从学校出来，然后支付，你知道，
$500 or $1,000 to do the basic training. But then you really need the second level training too. And then after you've done that, then you can say that you practice it when you're advertising. Then you can say you practice it when you have it on your description, but only after you've done these things and jumped through all these hoops. And then there's like the next, you know, and you're supposed to have multiple of these. I mean, and then they make you, tell you that, but the way to really make money with this modality is if you are a supervisor of people who are trying to train for it. And so then you do that extra training, and then you're just charging other
$500或$1,000来进行基础培训。但你真的也需要第二级培训。而在你做了这些之后，当你做广告时，你就可以说你实践它。当你把它写在你的描述中时，你就可以说你实践它，但只有在你做了这些事情并克服了所有这些障碍之后。然后就像下一个，你知道，而且你应该有多个这些。我的意思是，然后他们让你，告诉你那个，但真正用这种模式赚钱的方法是，如果你是那些试图为它培训的人的导师。所以然后你做那个额外的培训，然后你只是向其他
therapists to like spend an hour with you talking about that modality. And that's, that's where you're really supposed to make the money. I mean, I felt like that, and I don't know if y'all have this in your experience, but a lot of the like trainings and things that I'm really passionate about, you sort of get behind the curtain. And then that's like the, that's always the takeaway, like kind of at the end, it's like, I mean, and it makes sense to turn us into trainers, but it's, but it also just starts having this ring of like, like, wait a minute, but we're charged, so we're supposed to, our paycheck is supposed to come from other therapists
治疗师收费，让他们花一个小时和你谈论那种模式。而且那是，那是你真正应该赚钱的地方。我的意思是，我觉得那样，我不知道你们在你们的经验中是否有这个，但很多我真正热衷的培训和事情，你有点进入幕后。然后那就像是，那总是收获，就像在最后，就像，我的意思是，把我们变成培训师是有道理的，但它，但它也只是开始有这种感觉，就像，就像，等一下，但我们被收费，所以我们应该，我们的薪水应该来自其他治疗师
who barely make any money, and we know how this goes. That's, I don't know, it's parasitic or cannibalistic. Yeah. Like looking at you, Peter Levin and Richard Swartz, I mean, you're gonna have $15,000 in SE by the time you're done. Right. And which. I mean, you're going to have $15,000 in SE by the time you're done. I mean, this kind of, I know James has some thoughts on this, but I mean,
他们几乎赚不到钱，我们知道这是怎么回事。那，我不知道，它是寄生的或同类相食的。是的。就像看着你，彼得·莱文（Peter Levin）和理查德·斯瓦茨（Richard Swartz），我的意思是，当你完成时，你在SE（躯体体验）上会有15,000美元。对。而且这。我的意思是，当你完成时，你在SE上会有15,000美元。我的意思是，这种，我知道詹姆斯对此有一些想法，但我的意思是，
this gets me to one of the other points is we're bad at being able to figure out why something works and that it works separately in research. If research doesn't have a neurological description of something, it's very hesitant to say, hey, this works. People are liking it. I was talking to Matt Hongoltz-Hetling on one of the last podcasts about Anton Franz Mesmer, the guy who invented hypnosis, and he thought it worked because of Yeah, like he thought it worked because of animal magnetism and these things that are not objective that can't be seen, you know, it turns out magnets don't really do that much to animals. But all of those techniques of like energy and noticing somebody and matching their energy and regulating them semantically and
这让我想到其他观点之一，我们不擅长弄清楚为什么某事有效，以及它在研究中是分开有效的。如果研究没有某事的神经学描述，它非常犹豫是否说，嘿，这有效。人们喜欢它。我在最后几个播客之一中与马特·洪戈尔茨-赫特林（Matt Hongoltz-Hetling）谈论安东·弗朗茨·麦斯麦（Anton Franz Mesmer），那个发明催眠术的人，他认为它有效是因为……是的，就像他认为它有效是因为动物磁性以及这些不是客观的、看不见的东西，你知道，事实证明磁铁对动物并没有那么大的作用。但所有那些能量技术，注意到某人并匹配他们的能量，并在躯体上调节他们，以及
mirroring, those were the real reason why mesmerism was effective and later became medical hypnosis, which is a very valid thing. But the reason that he thought that it worked, that neurobiological reason, was not actually right. Same with EMDR. I mean, Shapiro made a perfectly good guess about why EMDR worked. Turns out that's not right, you know, 40 years of neurology later. But the technique is effective in some ways
镜像，那些才是麦斯麦术有效并后来成为医学催眠术的真正原因，这是一种非常有效的事情。但他认为它有效的原因，那个神经生物学原因，实际上并不正确。EMDR也是如此。我的意思是，夏皮罗（Shapiro）对EMDR为什么有效做了一个非常好的猜测。事实证明那是不对的，你知道，40年后的神经学。但这种技术在某些方面是有效的
that were taken by people like Dr. Vazquez and Dr. Crand and innovated on to create these other things. And a lot of times, if we just figure out that something works, I think research is very hesitant to say, hey, this is effective. Let's go find out why. Because they want to understand the root cause. And that just isn't how we discover things. I don't think I think innovation is a more squishy energy than that. Which is crazy, like going to anesthesiology, like they don't know why
被像瓦斯奎兹博士（Dr. Vazquez）和克兰德博士（Dr. Crand）这样的人采用并创新以创造这些其他东西。而且很多时候，如果我们只是弄清楚某事有效，我认为研究非常犹豫是否说，嘿，这是有效的。让我们去找出原因。因为他们想了解根本原因。而这根本不是我们发现事物的方式。我不认为，我认为创新是一种比那更软绵绵的能量。这太疯狂了，就像去麻醉学，他们不知道为什么
that works like anesthesia, they don't know why that works like anesthesia They don't know, you know, so there's no root cause of why when you get put under with any type of anesthetic They don't know why you just go. It's not a real sleep. It's not you're numb. You're not awake They have no they have Western medicine doesn't know like if you get into like go talk to Eastern medicine Then they can explain to you why consciousness works that way. But we don't acknowledge it here, because the ivory towers haven't caught up with that. Like, yeah, when nobody connects the dots, people don't understand, like, what, what that is. Yeah. But going with other modalities is, we don't trans, it doesn't translate well when you get into psychology and things like that. And again, going back to
那有效，就像麻醉，他们不知道为什么那有效，就像麻醉。他们不知道，你知道，所以当你被任何类型的麻醉剂麻醉时，没有根本原因。他们不知道为什么你只是走了。这不是真正的睡眠。这不是你麻木了。你没有醒着。他们没有，西方医学不知道，就像如果你进入，去和东方医学谈谈，那么他们可以向你解释为什么意识以那种方式工作。但我们在这里不承认它，因为象牙塔还没有赶上那个。就像，是的，当没有人连接点时，人们不明白，就像，那是什么。是的。但随着其他模式，我们不转换，当你进入心理学之类的事情时，它翻译得不好。而且再一次，回到
a bias of a revier in articles and what you want to publish, that, that blind revier, the one that we can't, you know, we don't know who they are, they might be, they might be a modality elitist of some different modality or some different thing, and have a different opinion and kind of, they're not supposed to, but there's always an innate bias within in in the human aspect. So they're going to look at this, whatever this new research in there and be like, ah, that sounds kind of weird, like, can they replicate this or just like this goes against CBT, you know, this is not what this is not at all. And that reviewer is going to mark up your research and gonna say, Yeah, that's not it. And then a lot of publications, a lot of journals are going to say it has to meet these requirements that it matches our reviewers perfectly. And, you know, but again, it's blind for you. So you don't know if you're going to get somebody that's going to be beneficial for you or detrimental. One of my guys, Dr. Burke, he says that he knows all these, a lot of these journals and what they look for. And so he literally formats his writing to those things, which I'm like, that's great.
关于文章审稿人的偏见，以及你想要发表的内容，那种盲审，我们不知道他们是谁，他们可能是某种特定模式的精英，或者有不同的观点。他们本不该有偏见，但人类天生就存在内在偏见。所以他们看这些新研究时会觉得，这听起来有点奇怪，他们能复现吗？或者这是否违背了认知行为疗法（CBT）？这不是他们想要的。审稿人会标记你的研究并说，这不对。很多期刊会要求必须符合这些标准，完全契合审稿人的口味。而且，这对你是盲审的，你不知道遇到的是对你有益还是有害的审稿人。我的一个朋友伯克博士说，他了解所有这些期刊以及它们想要什么，所以他会根据这些要求来调整自己的写作，我觉得这很棒。
You get published pretty easily, but what are you sacrificing for that? And it's a little deeper discussion with him, but yeah. Yeah, I mean, the quality is just totally different in having to, and if you want to, which I think the purpose of a big purpose of research is to bring forth new information and find new things and discover new things that we don't know,
你很容易发表文章，但为此牺牲了什么？这是一个更深层的话题，但确实，如果你的目的是为了提出新信息、发现我们未知的新事物，那么质量是完全不同的。
but we are so comfortable with, well, if it doesn't fit the standard, if we can't randomize control trial, or if it's not already published a million times prior that's already supported, then we don then we don't want to do it. There's a lot more fear in that to be able to do go in that direction. Well, I mean, so one of the things that I'd like to get y'all's opinion on, and some of you guys have a lot more experience directly with it than I do, but you know, when you say I have a problem with evidence-based practice,
但我们太安于现状了，如果它不符合标准，如果不能进行随机对照试验，或者如果之前没有被发表过一百万次并得到支持，那我们就不想做。朝着那个方向前进会有更多的恐惧。我想听听你们的意见，你们中有些人比我更有直接经验，但当你质疑循证实践时，
or what's the point of academic libraries, or. I mean the first thing that I get usually from psychology, clinical psychology students that have just taken their first research one-on-one class and googled me and decided that I'm a crank because I use brain spotting. That's the most frequent email that I get. They'll say oh well it's because it's peer reviewed, it's peer reviewed. So the content, again the concept of peer review that you would have people who know how to read science sit down and look At your article and not know who you are and not know their relationship to you or not Know you at all so that they can do that in a way without bias. I like that as an idea
或者质疑学术图书馆的意义时，我从刚上完第一门研究课、谷歌搜索过我并认定我是个疯子的临床心理学学生那里得到的第一反应，就是说我因为使用脑点疗法（Brainspotting）而不靠谱。这是我最常收到的邮件。他们会说，哦，这是因为它是同行评审的。所以，同行评审的概念是，让懂科学的人坐下来审阅你的文章，不知道你是谁，与你没有关系，甚至完全不认识你，这样他们就能在没有偏见的情况下进行评审。我喜欢这个想法。
As a practice, I don't think that the way that we do peer review right now does much and we have data on that I mean, what is it Alan Sokol in 1996? And then I think in like the 2010s Bohannon, you know These guys would just publish garbage to kind of it ends your career to do that. Like you have to kind of be academically Antagonistic which means that academia is not gonna like you but they would basically just put in like Sokol put in a whole bunch of Biases that he knew that people had And like Sokol put in a whole bunch of biases that he knew that people had about certain cultural ideas and then just published something that was just complete nonsense. Like he said that if you were transgressive and push boundaries, then it affected quantum gravity on this molecular level that they had seen like within cells or something.
但作为一种实践，我不认为我们现在的同行评审方式有多大作用，我们有相关数据。比如1996年的艾伦·索卡尔（Alan Sokal）事件，还有2010年代的博汉农（Bohannon），这些人只是发表垃圾文章来证明这一点。这样做会毁了你的职业生涯，你必须在学术上具有对抗性，这意味着学术界不会喜欢你。索卡尔基本上只是放入了一堆他知道人们对某些文化观念持有的偏见，然后发表了一些完全胡说八道的东西。比如他说，如果你具有越界性并突破界限，它就会影响分子层面的量子引力，就像他们在细胞内看到的那样。
And it got published over and over again. These organizations pick it up. So when people defend these things as like, well, this is what they do. We kind of have data, you know, evidence through science of people seeing if that process does anything. And time and time again, it doesn't really do much because the person who is just a burned out researcher who's having to do this for their job and not getting paid and then also like not even really aware of the thing that you're doing or sort of like in the same waters that
结果它被反复发表。这些组织采纳了它。所以当人们为这些事情辩护说“这就是他们的工作方式”时，我们其实有科学数据证明这个过程是否有效。事实证明，它并没有什么用，因为审稿人只是一个精疲力竭的研究人员，为了工作不得不做这些，没有报酬，甚至根本不了解你在做什么，或者和你不在同一个领域。
you're in even if you're in the same field being like yeah okay this is scientific is that really a peer review of a group of your actual you know ideological peers challenging and improving your thought process and your kind of scope of practice there i I don't know. I mean, what's y'all's experience with that? I will say my experience, because I've gone through peer review and have peer review publications, you typically do not have more than two individuals that peer review that article and then the editor will look over it. But they like the editor unless they just see a glaring red flag is going to go with whatever the peer review person said. And you think, oh, peer review people,
即使在同一个领域，他们说“好的，这是科学的”，这真的是由一群真正的意识形态同行来挑战并改进你的思维过程和实践范围吗？我不知道。你们对此有什么经验？我会说我的经验是，因为我经历过同行评审并发表过文章，通常审稿人不超过两个，然后编辑会审阅。除非有明显的红旗，否则编辑通常会听从审稿人的意见。你以为审稿人是受过训练的，不，他们只是你领域里的其他学者。所以根据主题，如果你在一个很小的、非常具体的科研圈子里，你通常能看出是谁在审你的稿，因为只有这些人能审，他们是仅有的研究和撰写相关内容的人。
they're like trained, they like, no, it's just other academics in your field. And so depending on the topic, a lot of times if you're in a small, very specific research community, you can tell who's peer reviewing your work because there's only those people who can peer review it because they are the only other ones that write about it and study it.
所以有时它真的不是盲审。我认为这个想法很好，但现实是你只是得到了两个人的观点，而他们称之为同行评审。我认为一个更公平的模式可能是将这些内容公开一段时间。就像在镇上修路，你必须公开张贴，看看谁有异议，谁有反馈。是的，过程中可能会有一些怪人，但你也会得到一些好的想法。我认为如果这些事情更公开、更透明一些，
So sometimes it really isn't blind. And I think, you know, the idea is good. But the reality is you're just getting two individual people's perspectives on your article and they're calling that peer review. Well, I think like a more equitable model too might be to make these things public for a period of time. Like if you're going to build a road in your town, you have to post it publicly and see who has objections, who has feedback. And yeah, you get some cranks, you know, in that process. But you also maybe get some good ideas. And I think that if these things were a little bit more
那么我们从大学里找两个精疲力竭的兼职讲师，可能会得到更好的结果，因为激励结构，特别是在心理学领域，奖励的是如果你有大量的钱，你就可以花钱把这些东西强行发表。我在策划这一集时想过，
public, a little bit more transparent, then we grabbed two burned out adjuncts from our university, you may get a better thing because the incentive structure, I think what it rewards, especially in psychology, is that if you've got a ton of money, you can just spend enough to ram one of these things through into publication. And I thought about when we were planning for this episode, um,
比如找一些我个人非常反感的大人物的研究，但我决定不那么小气，不去读他们的研究。但是，有很多在九十年代抨击分析心理学的人，说CBT很棒，解决了所有问题。我们不需要关系精神分析，不需要任何带有精神或更深层情感元素的东西，
like getting some of the research that's from like really big name people who I personally dislike. And I decided not to be that petty and like read their research on here. Um, but there's a ton of people who like really went after analytical psychology in the, in the nineties and talked about how CBT was wonderful and like it fixed everything. And like, we didn't need relational psychoanalysis. We didn't need anything that had any kind of like spiritual or deeper emotional element
比如情感转化疗法或荣格疗法。基本上就是说潜意识不是真的。这只是分析师为了榨取病人钱财和时间而编造出来的东西。有时候精神分析确实是浪费时间，但这并不意味着你证明了潜意识不是真的。他们发表了所有这些东西。
like emotional transformation therapy or Jungian therapy. Basically that the unconscious wasn't real. This was this thing that was just made up for analysts to suck up all the patient's money and take all this time, which sometimes psychoanalysis is a waste of time, but that doesn't, just because you prove that doesn't mean that you prove the unconscious isn't real. And they published all this stuff.
现在流行说“深层大脑中的创伤”之类的。所以同样的人，他们没有撤回任何东西。在发表了关于潜意识不是真的文章后，他们现在又有了论文，说认知有初级、二级和三级水平，底层包含更多象征性、非字面的成分，
Now it's trendy to be like, oh, trauma in the deep brain or whatever. So the same people, they didn't retract anything. They're now after publishing about the subconscious not being real, they now have these papers where they're like, well, their primary, secondary and tertiary, tertiary levels of cognition and the bottom levels contain more of a symbolic less literal component
还有躯体反应，你知道，能量的情感释放。你会想，哦，你是想说该死的潜意识吗？这些人都不必承认自己错了。他们不必收回任何东西。他们能够发表这些东西。有一个人特别不喜欢脑点疗法，所以他偶尔会发表一些东西，虽然是在非常大的期刊上，但文章没有任何价值。比如其中一篇他说，我听说过这个脑点疗法，我没有受过培训，我从来没做过。
and also somatic reactions that budget emotional, you know, releases of energy. And you're like, oh, you mean a fucking unconscious is what you're trying to say. None of these people had to say they're wrong. They didn't have to take anything back. I mean, they're able to publish those things. There's a guy that particularly just likes brain spotting. And so he'll publish stuff every once in a while, but there's very big name journals, but there's nothing of merit in the article. Like there's one of them where he says, I heard about this brain spotting thing. I've not trained in it. I've never done it.
但它的理论之一是它以某种方式参与了皮层下大脑。我记得我在1980年上医学院时，这是在学术出版物中，大脑中所有的记忆并不都在皮层下大脑，所以那里没有记忆。大脑中记忆在哪里是认知科学中最复杂的问题之一。
But the one of the theories of it is that it's somehow engaging the subcortical brain. And I remember when I went to medical school in 1980, this is like in an academic publication. All of the memory in the brain is not in the subcortical brain, so there's no memory there. Like where memory is in the brain is one of the most complicated questions
而你却有个人发表文章说，他记得他成为医生时在不同领域的教科书内容，这居然能发表在学术心理学刊物上。所以如果你想谈论同行评审和专业化，为什么这些人被允许发表文章？
in all of cognitive science. And you've got somebody who's publishing something saying that they remember their textbook from when they became a doctor in a different field that's somehow publishing in academic psych publications. So if you wanna say peer review and specialization and whatever, why are these guys allowed to publish?
因为他们有钱。因为他们可以通过花钱强行发表。有很多掠夺性出版集团。这是资本主义模式的一部分，有很多期望支付数千美元来发表你的文章。或者如果你尝试在其他不需要付费的地方发表，他们不接受。但你总能找到一个只要你付钱就愿意接受的地方。如果只是花钱买发表，那怎么能叫同行评审呢？我认为这也是问题的一大部分。我认为有一点可能会有帮助，因为你会遇到的问题之一是，因为我知道我会回复很多我收到的邮件，我认为其中一些是真诚的，即使有些是有点被误导的。
It's because they're rich. It's because they can ram these things through by spending money. There are a lot of predatory publishing groups. I mean, that's just part of the capitalistic model of this, where there's a lot of expectation to pay thousands of dollars to get your article published. Or if you have tried to publish multiple other places where
我记得我在本科学习比较宗教学时，学到了很多关于荣格和躯体心理学的东西。然后当我拿到学位时，我想，好吧，龙与地下城、世界构建和创造性的东西都结束了。现在我要成为一名严肃的治疗师来做科学。我学到CBT是最好的。我读了所有关于它的书，一直觉得，但这似乎有点显而易见，对吧？就像你弹一下橡皮筋，告诉焦虑停止。
you say you don't have to pay, they won't accept it. But you can always find one that will take it if you pay enough money. And so how is that peer reviewed if you're just buying your article to be published? I mean, I think that's a big part of the problem, too I think that one thing that may be helpful is because one of the questions that you're gonna get because you know I do respond to a lot of the emails that I get from people that you know, I think are genuine, you know even if some of its kind of misguided.
这似乎行不通。当我刚开始工作时尝试用它治疗病人，病人并没有产生共鸣。所以我只是遵循了我发现有效的方法，最终学会了相信自己，走了一条与被告知的方向完全不同的路，
And I remember that, like, I learned a lot of kind of like Jungians and somatic psychology when I was in undergrad when I was doing comparative religion. And then when I went to go get my degree, I was like, Okay, time, that's all for D&D and world building and creative stuff. Now I'm going to be a serious therapist to do science. And I learned that CBT was the best thing. And I read all these books on it and kept being like, but this seems kind of obvious, you know? Like you snap a rubber band and tell the anxiety to stop.
或者与激励指向的方向完全不同。所以我认为人们发那些邮件并不是因为他们愚蠢，或者因为他们想表现得咄咄逼人，我认为他们还在学校，他们处于我曾经的位置，我能理解，所以我并不评判。但他们总是问的一个大问题是，好吧，那你怎么做？好吧，我想我们应该取消执照，取消委员会，然后用晶体和彩虹来治疗一切。
Like this doesn't seem like it goes. When I was trying it with patients, when I was first working and patients weren't resonating with it. And so I just followed what I found to be effective, which I ended up, you ended up learning to trust myself, going somewhere that was totally different than where I was kind of told to go
当然，我不是那个意思。所以如果我们回到影响因子系统、H指数系统、学术出版业，有什么真正简单且可能，我不想说两党制，因为它不是政治性的，但只是普遍接受的解决方案，任何愿意创造性地思考这些东西的人都会说，哦，是的，那是个好主意。我们能做些什么来改变它、修复它，你知道，明天就做？这是一个大问题。但我认为对我来说，第一件事是，
or where the incentives pointed at me. So I don't think that people send those emails because they're stupid or because they want to be aggressive or something like, I think that they're in school, they're in the same place that I was and I relate to it So I'm not I'm not judging it But like the the big question that they always have is like, okay, so how would you do it? All right, I guess we should just get rid of licensors just get rid of boards and we treat everything with crystals and rainbows
它不能被资本主义激励。比如支付结构，它的设置方式，整个学术界的结构。我认为这些是学术界如何设置的系统性大问题，它非常精英主义，而且它已经变成了那样，很多学者想保持这种状态。
And you know, of course, that's not what I'm saying So if we go back to the impact factor system the h H index system, the academic publishing industry, what are like really easy and probably, I don't want to say bipartisan, because it's not political, but just universally accepted solutions that anybody who's willing to kind of sit creatively with this stuff would be like, Oh, yeah, that's a good idea. What could we do to change it, fix it, you know, tomorrow? That's a big question. But I think that at least the first thing for me is like,
所以我认为这是弄清楚如何支持学术界的人，以及如何将研究成果传达给大众，或者传达给治疗师或任何在专业领域工作的人的一大部分。很多这些抱怨并不是我脑子里编出来的，因为我与研究没有太多的重叠。它们来自与医生、研究人员的对话，
it cannot be capitalistically incentivized. Like the pay structure, the way that it's set up, the structure of the academy in general. I think these are systemic larger issues of how the academy is set up and it's very elitist and it's very, and it's meant, you know, it's become that and academics, a lot of academics wanna keep it that way.
他们也在抱怨这些事情，因为他们想发现东西。我的很多观点来自与那些正在制造有趣事物的人交谈，我打电话给他们看他们是否愿意和我交谈。你知道，我读的研究可能比大多数治疗师都多，因为我对这些东西很感兴趣。这就是为什么当我觉得它没有应有的效果时，我会感到生气。所以我认为只要倾听领域内的人的声音，海莉，当你说学术界里的很多人不开放时，
And so I think that's a big part of figuring out how to support people in the Academy and also be able to get people that research to the general population or also to therapists or anyone who works in any kind of specialized field that there's research being done. Well, and a lot of these complaints are not things that like I make up in my head because I don't have like a ton of overlap with research. They come from conversations with doctors, with researchers
你是在赶走所有那些不仅仅有直觉和创造性冲动，并且为了——找不到更好的词——正确理由而从事这一行的人。你把所有那些人都赶走了，你还剩下什么？你有一个博士学位，但你没有做研究，因为你觉得你在治疗中能帮助更多的人。我替你说了，但你对此有一些问题。你能告诉我们那些事情吗？是的，绝对。我是一名社会工作领域的定性研究员，即使在社会工作内部。我进入这个领域时确实戴着玫瑰色的眼镜，因为我回去读博士不是为了做研究，而是因为我想成为一名优秀的从业者。
who are also complaining about these things because they want to discover stuff. I mean, that's where a lot of my perspective comes from is talking to people who are making things that are interesting that I call up and see if they'll talk to me. You know, I probably read more research than most therapists because I'm really interested in this stuff. And that's why it makes me angry when I feel like it isn't as effective as it could be So, I mean I think just listening to the people in the field and I mean, you know Haley when you're saying that like a lot of the people like in that Academy are not are not Open to it
我想能够将研究和临床工作结合起来，以解决我们所看到的一些系统性问题。但当你进入那里时，你感觉自己就像机器里的一个齿轮。我想，是的，科学很重要，但它是科学与艺术。它是艺术与科学的结合。
Well, you're driving out everybody who's not just gonna have this intuition and kind of creative impulse and like being in it for the lack Of a better word the right reasons you drive all all those people out what are you left with? I mean you have a PhD and you're not doing research because you felt like you were going to help more people in therapy. I'm going to speak for you there but you had some problems with it. Can you tell us about those things? Yeah absolutely. I mean one I'm a qualitative researcher in the social work field and even within social work. I really had the rose colored glasses on going into it because I didn't go back to get a PhD. I went back because I wanted to be a good practitioner.
我认为这是非常重要的一部分。这就是创造性的一面，以及探索和研究我们社会中、文化中、社区中正在发生的社会现象的一面，或者我们从治疗师那里听到的反馈，比如这正在发生，但没有人研究它。然后你会想，好吧，那我们就研究它。
I wanted to be able to use research and clinical work together to be able to address some of these systemic issues that we were seeing. But when you get in there, you are a cog in a machine is really what it felt like for me. And I was like, well, yes, science is important, but it's science and art. It's art and science together.
然后你进入学术界，他们会说，哦，我们不想谈论那个。那太政治化了。你知道，有一种结构，对你表现的期望非常强烈，很多时候是心照不宣的。但很早就表现得很明显，如果你想做定性研究，要知道这会比别人难两倍。如果你是定量的，你更有可能获得终身教职，这又是把一切简化为数字，而人不是数字。
I think that is such a big piece of it. And that's like where that creative side and that exploring and research side of what is going on, the social phenomenon that we see going on socially, culturally within our communities, or we're hearing feedback from therapists, like this is happening, but nobody's studying it. And then you're like, OK, well, we'll just study it.
每个人的经历都是不同的。我们不是计算机。生物医学模式的很大一部分是试图证明，如果你收集了所有数据、所有变量，你真的可以破解这个密码，拥有一个完美的治疗模型，完全变成一个公式，完全没有提供者的洞察力，
And then you get in the academy, and it's like, ooh, we don't want to talk about that. That's too politicized you know there is a structure that the expectation of how you will perform is Very strong a lot of times it's unspoken But it's made pretty evident pretty early on that if you want to do qual just just know it's going to be twice as hard for you. You are more likely to get a tenure track job if you are quantitative, which again is distilling everything down to numbers and people aren't numbers.
完全没有病人的主观体验，完全没有定量变量。它不能仅仅简化为一个数字。我不认为你永远能解决那个问题。有一件事困扰我，詹姆斯，你谈到精神科医生是如何受训的。如果我是护士，我的老板是护士，对吧？委员会或做账单的人，他们是医学背景的。
Everyone's experience is different. We're not computers. So much of the biomedical model has been this attempt to prove that if you just get all the data, all the variables, you can really just sort of crack the code of this and have the perfect model of therapy that is completely turned into a formula, completely without provider insight,
如果我是工程师，我的老板是工程师。如果我是治疗师，为什么一个可能从未接受过治疗、从未受过治疗培训的人，是决定保险索赔是否通过、我做的是否是真实治疗的人？这不是治疗师在做决定。是一个生物医学医生，他可能对安非他酮和抗生素了解很多，但在我的经验中，很少能找到
completely without patient subjective experience, and completely without quantitative variables. It can't just be reduced down to a number. And I don't think you're ever going to solve that problem. And one of the things that bothers me, James, you were talking about how psychiatrists are trained. If I'm a nurse, my boss is a nurse, right? The boards or the people that do billing, they're medical.
那些人中有人曾作为病人接受过治疗，这是理解它如何运作的一部分，而且除了六次CBT培训之外，从未接受过治疗培训，告诉病人改变行为，如果这不能减轻症状，那就继续用药，你知道，这就是我看到的。我不知道这是否是我会遇到的事情。我想说的是，我认为它已经变成了食谱模式，你知道，一切都只是公式或配方，为了让你得到这个产品。我共事过的一位医生说，我讨厌食谱模式，没有人能一次又一次地适应这个特定的东西。即使在学校里，你也会被灌输学习CBT，因为那是领域里能成功的东西。它很容易教，很容易在人身上复现，你可以成为一名伟大的治疗师，但却是一个糟糕的CBT从业者。反之亦然，你可以成为一名伟大的CBT从业者，但不是一名伟大的治疗师。
If I'm an engineer, my boss is an engineer. If I'm a therapist, why is somebody who's probably never been in therapy, who's not really ever been trained in therapy, the one who's deciding whether or not insurance claims go through, if what I'm doing is real, you know, like what I should be trained in to be on the, an insurance panel, it's not a therapist who's making that call. It's a biomedical doctor who may know a whole lot about well, butrin and antibiotics, but it's very rare in my experience to find any
我认为我们已经失去了好奇心去寻找真正有效的东西。我记得我在研究生院大开眼界的是学习危机干预。那根本不是CBT，对吧？在危机时刻，你不是在改变一个婴儿，你是在试图改变危机中将要发生的结果。所以你甚至不是……但就是这样。在学校里学习危机干预是什么样子是一件大事。但你知道，当我了解到正念减压疗法能做什么并看到相关研究时，那是毕业后的事，我当时想，哦，这太棒了。为什么我在读研时不知道这个，并且
of those people that's ever been in therapy as a patient which is part of understanding how it works and and ever been in therapy training beyond you know six sessions of CBT tells the person to change their behavior and then if that doesn't reduce the symptom then you go ahead and do drugs you know that's what I see. I don't know if that's something I'll encounter. Well, I was gonna say that I think that it's gone to the cookbook model, you know, where everything is just, yeah, a formula or recipes to kind of get you this product. And there's a doctor that I worked with that was just like, I hate the cookbook model, nobody could fit in this specific thing over and over again. Which is, even in school, like, you get, you get hammered out and learn CBT, because that's the thing that's going to make it in the field. And it's easy to teach, it's easy to replicate in the person, you can be a great therapist, but a terrible CBT practitioner. And I think that and vice versa, you could be a great CBT practitioner, but not a great therapist.
基本上免费接受培训？他们不提供，你知道，CBT是免费培训。我可以快速插一句吗？我认为这也不同，取决于你读的是什么样的研究生项目。是的，因为你们都是社会工作者。但在咨询领域，我们学习的结构非常不同。CBT在本科时很大，我在科罗拉多大学博尔德分校。那是博尔德模式，那里非常强调研究。所以CBT就像植入到了我的心理学本科水平中。但一旦我进入研究生院，它真的就像，这是我们谈论内容的非常基础的部分。然后
And I think we've lost our inquisitive minds to kind of fit things that work. I remember my eye-opening in grad school was learning crisis intervention. What is not CBT at all? Like there is, you're not, in a moment of crisis, you're not you're not changing a baby, you're trying to change an outcome of what's going to happen in that crisis. And so you're not even but that's it. That was a huge thing going through school was like, what is crisis intervention look like. But you know, when I learned what mindfulness based stress reduction can do and saw the so the research on that,, I mean, that's I was I had to, that was after school, where I was like, Oh, this, this is awesome. Why didn't I know this when I was going through grad school and
全是其他类型的模式，比如正念、躯体疗法和基于创伤的视角。所以它确实取决于你读的是什么项目，以及教授是谁，研究是什么，什么得到了资助。我知道，在咨询师、婚姻家庭治疗师（MFT）如何受训，与社会工作者、心理学家、精神科医生相比，有一些细微的差别。我们没有承认这一点，比如有些人可能，我读的是KCREP咨询心理学和咨询教育，在那里你实际上学习教育其他咨询师。所以有一个完整的元水平，
have free training, basically, in it? They don't, you know, it's free training and CBT. Why take up for can I just really quick take up? I think it's also different, like, depending on what kind of grad program you're doing. Yeah, cuz y'all are all social workers But like within the field of counseling like your are the structure of what we're learning is so different like CBT was big and undergrad And my psycho, you know in my and which I went to University of Colorado at Boulder. It's the Boulder model It's all about there's a major research emphasis there So CBT was like baked into just my psychology grade and undergrad level. But once I got to grad school, it was really like, this is like very beginning of what we talked about. And
但有各种各样不同的教育类型和治疗师类型。但我们谈论的是这个领域的锚点。是什么还在支撑着我们。这就像是一个接触点，它正在创造这个，它从领域中抽走了创造力，抽走了从业者的独立性。而且很无聊。你知道，它很无聊，因为它在这一点上并不创新。它看起来确实完全独立于从业者。而且很无聊。你知道，它很无聊，因为它在这一点上并不创新。
then it was all, all other types of modalities like that, you know, like mindfulness and somatic stuff and trauma based perspectives. So it really, I mean, it does really depend on like what program you're going to and what you're, you know, what, what the perspectives are and that is dictated by like who the, you know, it gets back to like who the professors are, what the research is and what's getting funded. But I know, you know, they're just different little subtle differences and in like how counselors and MFTs are trained versus social workers versus psychologists versus psychiatrists. And we kind of don't acknowledge that like some of us might have like, I went to a KCREP counseling psychology and counselor education, where you actually learn to educate other counselors. And so there's this whole meta level,
它看起来确实像，你知道，CBT之类的东西。感觉它到目前为止只是直觉知识，但是。好吧，如果我们能谈谈生物医学模式是什么，因为我不认为生物医学模式是一件坏事。
but there's totally tons of different types of education and like types of therapists that are out there. But what we are talking about is like kind of therapists that are out there. But what we are talking about is like kind of the anchor of the field. What's really like still like holding us. It's like this touch point of which is kind of creating this, you know, it's just it zaps the creativity from the field and it zaps the independence of the practitioners. And it's boring. You know, it's boring because it's not at this point innovative. It does seem like it's absolutely independent of the practitioners. And it's boring. You know, it's boring because it's not at this point innovated.
我认为它永远是护理的一部分。你知道，如果有人进来，他们不知道如果他们不睡觉，或者不知道如何获得睡眠，他们的抑郁或焦虑就不会减轻。如果有人进来，他们喝了太多的酒或使用了非法药物，而你只是说，好吧，我们不必担心所有这些讨厌的知识和技能。我只是要用瑜伽和冥想来治愈这个。
It does seem like it's like, you know, CBT and stuff like that. It feels like it's just intuitive knowledge by this point, but. Well, and if we could talk a little bit about what the biomedical model is, because I don't really think that the biomedical model is a bad thing.
好吧，也许每天喝五分之一瓶酒是首先要解决的更重要的事情。那种生物医学模式是你永远会与之对话的东西，我们也应该这样。我只是不认为它能包含所有的意识，能包含所有的治疗工作，
I think it's always gonna be a part of care. You know, if somebody comes in and they don't know that if they don't get sleep or if they don't know how to get sleep, that their, you know, depression or anxiety is not going to come down. If somebody comes in and they're using too much alcohol or they're using illegal drugs and you just say, all right, we don't have to worry about all this pesky intellectual knowledge and skills. I'm just going to cure this with yoga and meditation.
因为它的核心是说，这里有一张检查清单。当我们勾选这些框时，你就有了这种障碍，而这种障碍，我们将研究它对哪些治疗有反应。所以当研究中的所有其他人勾选了这些框，我们给了他们这种障碍，
Well, I mean, yeah, maybe drinking a fifth a day is the more important thing first. That biomedical model is something that is something that you're always going to be in conversation with and we should be. I just, I don't think that it's something that can contain all of consciousness, that can contain all of therapeutic work,
让我们看看，你知道，哪些模型让它上升或下降。现在我们知道，如果你有广泛性焦虑障碍，如果你有双相情感障碍I型，那么，这就是有效的治疗方法。这就是无效的治疗方法。大方向上，我认为这没问题。但即使你按字面意思理解他们，
because at its heart, what it's doing is saying, here's a list of check boxes. And when we check these boxes, then you now have this disorder, and this disorder, we're gonna study which treatments it responds to. And so when all these other people in the study checked those boxes and we gave them this disorder,
他们也不想使用那个模型。他们不想继续深入下去。我们知道像多动症（ADHD）这样的东西，我们已经知道很长时间了。我想阿明博士在70年代或80年代就说过。你可以看QEG脑图，你可以看到有六种不同的事情
let's see, you know, which models made that go up or down. And now we know that if you have generalized anxiety disorder, if you have bipolar one, that, you know, this is the kind of therapy that works. This is the kind of therapy that doesn't. Broad strokes, I think that's fine. But even when you take them at their word,
可能在大脑中发生，导致ADHD的相同框被勾选，并对相同的药物有反应。但它们不是同一回事。所以你把它们当作同一种障碍来治疗。如果你回去指出这一点，他们只会说，哦，好吧，对每个人都做QEG脑图来看看他们到底有什么障碍是不现实、不有效或不划算的。
it's like, they don't want to use that model. They don't want to go ahead and go all the way with it. We know that something like ADHD, like we've known for a really long time. I mean, I think Dr. Amin said this in the 70s or maybe the 80s. You can look at a QEG brain map, and you can see that there are six different things that
所以，这看起来像是生物医学模式在说，哦，好吧，模型本身太不方便了。所以我们只是要这样做。我的意思是，即使你想按照他们说的方式去做，也有一些地方你可以做得更好，但他们仍然不想去。这有意义吗？
can happen in the brain that result in the same boxes being checked for ADHD and respond to the same medication. But they're not the same thing. So you're treating them like they're the same disorder. And if you go back and you point something like that out, they're just going to be like, oh, well, it's not realistic or effective or cost effective to go ahead and do a QAG brain
或者詹姆斯，你在医院里见过那些两难困境吗？哦，一直都有。显然在会诊精神病学中，你会进入医学方面。有很多事情发生，那些你在医院外无法复现的事情。显然在医院外，但那些事情确实存在，我有点想不起来了。我刚收到一封关于某事的邮件，但是的，我们确实经常有那些情况。我的意思是你会看到
map for everybody to see which disorder they actually have. So I mean, that seems like it's the biomedical model being like, Oh, well, the model itself is kind of too inconvenient. So we're just going to do it this way. I mean, even if you want to do it the way that they're saying that they want to do it, um, then there's places that you could do that better that they still don't want to go. Does that sort of make sense?
我们控制之外的事情起着很大的作用，作为治疗师，与我们共事的人。无论我们共事的人是否在做我们希望他们做的事情，很难设定空间。好吧，让我们设定一点，因为我认为我们没有承认的一件事，也许是最重要的一件事，是我们的客户
Or James, do you have any kind of, have you seen those catch 22s in the hospital? Oh, all the time. Obviously in consult psychiatry, you're going to wrap into on the medicine side. There's a lot of things that go on, um, that are just not the things that you're not able to replicate out anywhere else. Um, outside of the hospital hospital obviously, but there's there's Yeah, the those things exist and it's I'm kind of drawing a blank. I just got an email about something but um Yes, we did have those a lot I mean you see you're gonna see that
是他们自己的专家。是的。你共事的每个人都是他们自己的专家。他们不需要知道研究中有什么，就能知道他们对自己的体验是什么。所以只要我们把别人放在上面，我们这里就发生了整个等级制度的事情。
They things outside of our control play a big role like as a therapist with the people that we work with. And it's whether or not, if the person that we're working with is doing the things that we want them to or not, it is hard to kind of set the space. Well, and like, let's just set a little bit, cause I think that one thing we're not acknowledging and maybe the most important thing is that our clients
我们坐在这里感觉像谦卑的治疗师，为什么没有人关注我们？但实际上，受苦的人是我们的客户。他们只是在尖叫，甚至更多地用头撞墙。我的意思是，有时真的是试图找到一个不仅仅是动机访谈和CBT的治疗师，谁会真正把他们当作一个真实的人来对待，在他们所在的地方与他们见面，并在治疗中做出反应，而不是仅仅是规定性的。
are the experts on themselves. Yeah. And every individual you work with is an expert on themselves. They don't have to know about what is in the research to know what their experience of themselves is. And so as long as we're putting somebody else, we have this whole hierarchical thing happening over here.
海莉，你见过类似的事情吗，生物医学模式与他们试图附加的这些新想法之间存在张力？比如，哦，一切都应该是以人为本的，或者我们应该保持人在环境中的概念，或者我们应该有更多那样的东西。因为我看到人们回来时说，哦，是的，我们培训了你们CBT，但现在行业在说创伤，所以我们要搞CBTTF之类的。我们要给思域车加个扰流板，把它变成另一辆车。你见过这样的事情吗？因为你在博士世界里的经验可能比我们任何人都多。是的，令人惊讶的是，作为一名博士，即使在社会工作中，也不是真正的社会工作或治疗或治疗性的。
And we're sitting here feeling like humble therapists. we have this whole hierarchical thing happening over here. And we're sitting here feeling like humble therapists, like why won't anybody pay attention to us? But really like people who are suffering are our clients. And they're just screaming out like even more so and beating their heads against the wall. I mean, sometimes literally trying to like find a therapist who's not just gonna like just motivational energy interviewing and like CBT, like it's in who will actually relate to them as like a real human and meet them where they are and like be responsive in their treatment instead of just prescriptive.
我的意思是，如果你学习某些东西，你确实会学到，但博士模式很大程度上是由医学模式驱动的。所以无论医学做什么，它都是其他研究项目的标准。无论医学做什么，那都是其他人想做的。因为那是他们看到的成功方式。这就是我看到的盈利方式。我认为确实存在这种张力，对吧，我们想要一个答案来解决问题，我们想在做之前知道它有效。但人类不是那样工作的。你知道，这就像你说的，爱丽丝，它真的带走了所有的创造力，带走了你使用自己直觉、倾听和与客户互动的能力。而且，它真的把所有的责任都放在了治疗师身上，让他们成为房间里的专家。更不用说，这对治疗师来说压力很大，但这也不是它应该有的样子。这，你知道，我们，它是如此自上而下。这个模型是如此驱动，以至于即使你试图做，他们跳过障碍的能力比仅仅聪明更重要。就像如果你
Haley, have you seen anything like that, where the biomedical model is sort of in tension with these newer ideas they're trying to tack on? Like, oh, everything should be person-centered, or we should maintain a concept of person in the environment, or we should have more of that. Because I see people coming back and being like, oh, yeah, we trained y'all on CBT, but now the industry is saying trauma, so we're going to do CBTTF or something. We're going to attack a spoiler on the Civic to make it a different car. Do you see things like that? Because you have probably more experience in the PhD world than any of us. Yeah. And surprisingly enough, being a PhD, even in social work is not really social work or therapy or therapeutic.
能弄清楚系统并学会如何跳过障碍，你就能成功，但代价是什么呢？每个研究人员都必须真正问自己，这是什么？你不可能成为一名研究人员而不身处其中，几乎不可能成为一名研究人员而不被置于这个模型中。很难打破它。如果你按字面意思理解这些模型，并查看客观研究想要研究关于心理学的一切，你会错过我们所做很多事情的真正重点。因为对我来说，当你把焦虑变成诊断，当你把抑郁变成诊断时，你正在把这些东西从它们来源的真正根源上切断，很多时候我们想考虑这些东西
I mean, you do learn if you study certain things, but the PhD model is very much driven by the medical model. And so whatever medicine does, it's kind of the standard for other research programs. Whatever medicine does, that's what everybody else wants to do. Because that's how they've seen it's been successful. That's how I see it's profitable. And I think there is like, this tension, right, between we want an answer to fix things, and we want to know that it works before we do it. But that's just not how humans work. You know, that's just like what you were saying, Alice, like it just really takes all the creativity, all your ability to use your own intuition and to listen and to engage with the client. And it's, it's really putting all the oneness on the therapist to be the expert in the room. And not to mention, that's a lot of pressure on a therapist, but that's also not how it should be. This, you know, we, it's so top down. The model is so driven that way, that even if you are trying to do a their ability to jump keep jumping through the hoops than necessarily just being smart. Like if you
比如基因，你不会像得癌症那样得焦虑症。你不会像得流感那样得焦虑症，然后你服用这种逆转录病毒或抗生素。你得焦虑症是因为你的生活中缺乏平衡，也许你正在超越一个旧的身份，你需要放手那个身份的部分，去听见一个更大的你，你需要记住的。你抑郁可能是因为你强迫自己适应一个你甚至不知道是盒子的盒子，但你把盒子误认为是你是谁，或者你所能成为的一切。你得焦虑和抑郁以及所有这些东西，作为动态力量的一部分，需要一定程度的主观性和一定程度的永远无法成为公式的东西，才能真正坐下来帮助某人听见我是谁，我想成为什么。而很多时候
can figure out the system and learn how to jump through the hoops you can be successful but at what cost you know and each researcher has to really ask themselves is this what you can't be a researcher and not be in it's just it's almost impossible to be a researcher and not be set within this model. It's very hard to break out of it. of where if you took these models at face value and you looked at everything that objective research wants to research about psychology where you would be kind of missing the real point of, I think, a lot of what we do. Because to me, when you take anxiety and you turn it into a diagnosis, when you take depression and you turn it into a diagnosis, you're cutting these things off from the real root of where they come from, which a lot of times we wanna think about this stuff
能够弄懂这个系统并学会如何应对各种繁文缛节，你或许能取得成功，但代价是什么呢？每个研究人员都必须扪心自问，难道这就是……你不可能成为一名研究人员却不身处其中，几乎不可能在不被这个模式束缚的情况下进行研究。想要打破它非常困难。如果你从表面上看这些模型，并审视客观研究想要探究的所有心理学课题，你会发现这在某种程度上偏离了我们所做工作的核心意义。因为对我来说，当你把焦虑变成一种诊断，把抑郁变成一种诊断时，你就切断了这些问题与它们真正根源的联系，而我们往往倾向于认为这些问题是……
like genes, and you don't get anxiety like you get cancer. You don't get anxiety like you get the flu and then you take this retroviral or you take this antibiotic. Like you get anxiety because there's a lack of balance in your life, maybe you're outgrowing like an older identity and you need to let go of parts of that identity to hear a greater whole of you that you need to remember. You get depressed maybe when you're making yourself fit a box that you never even knew was a box, but you mistook the box for who you were or all that you could be. You get anxiety and depression and all of these things as part of dynamic forces that it takes a certain amount of subjectivity and a certain amount of things that can never be a formula to really sit with and help someone hear who am I, what do I want to be. And so many times
就像基因一样，你患上焦虑症的方式并不像患上癌症那样。你患上焦虑症的方式也不像患上流感然后服用抗逆转录病毒药物或抗生素那样。你之所以感到焦虑，是因为你的生活失去了平衡，也许你正在超越旧的自我，需要放下那部分身份，去倾听一个更完整的自我，一个你需要重新认识的自我。你感到抑郁，也许是因为你强迫自己去适应一个你甚至不知道是“盒子”的框架，却误以为那个盒子就是你，或者你所能成为的一切。你产生焦虑、抑郁以及所有这些情绪，都是动态力量的一部分，需要一定的主观性，也需要一些永远无法公式化的东西，才能真正静下心来，帮助某人去倾听“我是谁，我想成为什么样的人”。而这种情况实在太多了。
those goals that somebody comes in with of I want to bite my fingernails, I don't want to drink alcohol anymore, I can't sleep. When you really listen to that, what happens is that you go a whole lot deeper into a person and into a problem. And the people who are going to the oncologist, they know what the problem is. And the way that the people going to therapy know the beginning of this pathway,
那些人们带着的目标，比如我想戒掉咬指甲，我不想再喝酒了，我睡不着觉。当你真正倾听这些时，你会更深入地了解一个人和问题所在。去看肿瘤科医生的人，他们知道问题是什么。就像去接受心理治疗的人知道这条路径的起点一样，
but it's not the end and it's not the whole thing in a way that I think we've we've are in the process of kind of losing as a profession in a way that's scary to me. Can you all have kind of examples in your work where the I don't know I mean we we all are kind of in the same world but we work differently. Are there places where you know you get somewhere with subjectivity you never would have gotten with kind of an empirical objective method alone? Yeah. I mean, I still think everything to me, and the field is moving in this direction a little bit, but how trauma does inform
但这并不是终点，也不是全部。我认为我们作为一个专业领域正在失去这一点，这让我感到害怕。你们在工作中是否有这样的例子？我不知道，我的意思是，我们都在同一个世界，但工作方式不同。有没有一些地方，你通过主观性获得了一些仅靠经验主义客观方法永远无法获得的东西？是的。我的意思是，我仍然认为对我来说，整个领域正在朝着这个方向发展，但创伤确实影响了
pretty much everything that I see. And I think therapists on the ground, more so than psychiatrists, I mean, psychiatrists are still out there diagnosing everyone with borderline. And I think that that's sort of a, I have opinions there, but it's sort of a made up thing. And it's really complex trauma that we're seeing. And then among that population, the interface between trauma symptoms and ADHD symptoms, trauma symptoms and autism, and then the compounded,
我所看到的几乎所有事情。我认为一线治疗师比精神科医生更了解这一点，我的意思是，精神科医生仍然在给每个人诊断边缘型人格障碍。我认为这是一种，我对此有自己的看法，但这是一种虚构的东西。我们看到的是非常复杂的创伤。在这一人群中，创伤症状与多动症（ADHD）症状、创伤症状与自闭症之间的交集，以及复合的，
like because you grow up with autism, that is traumatic to be a, to have like the world like set up not for you and like not reflecting back what your experience is. But so everything and so trying to differentiate whereas like psychiatry wants to throw everybody in the same boat of like, okay, this person is just emotionally erratic. It's like just a modern way of saying hysterical, hysteria. But there are so many subtle aspects
比如因为你在自闭症中成长，这本身就是一种创伤，因为世界并不是为你而设的，也没有反映出你的真实体验。所以一切都是如此，试图去区分它们。而精神病学想把每个人都归为一类，认为这个人只是情绪不稳定。这就像是“歇斯底里”的现代说法。但有太多微妙的方面
and we get into autism and there's like, I mean, we could do episodes and episodes, but about differences in consciousness and how that works and like what we should be pathologizing and what really is like a higher method or a higher way of being in a lot of cases. But trying to differentiate that when it's like I'll get these patients and it's like they've been just like labeled borderline since they were 13 and it's like okay what what are we actually seeing here?
当我们谈到自闭症时，我的意思是，我们可以做很多期节目来讨论，但关于意识的差异以及它是如何运作的，以及我们应该将什么病理化，而在很多情况下，什么实际上是一种更高的机制或更高的存在方式。但当病人被贴上边缘型人格障碍的标签长达13年之久时，试图去区分这些，就像是，好吧，我们到底在这里看到了什么？
Like did you cut one time and somebody gave you a borderline diagnosis? That's automatically what I hear. And again not to beat up on the on the researchers and the doctors, because, you know, if you are a woman and you try to like, you know, have a suicide attempt or you you present in distress and you get sent to the ER, you're probably going to get a diagnosis of borderline personality disorder on that discharge. And I think that's wrong because they don't have time to assess that. They don't know if your reaction was a normal or understandable reaction to the environment that you're coming out of. And a lot of times they a normal or understandable reaction to the environment
比如你是不是因为自残了一次，别人就给了你一个边缘型人格障碍的诊断？我听到的自动就是这样。再说一次，不是要抨击研究人员和医生，因为，你知道，如果你是一名女性，你试图自杀，或者你表现出痛苦并被送往急诊室，你很可能会在出院时得到边缘型人格障碍的诊断。我认为这是错误的，因为他们没有时间去评估。他们不知道你的反应是否是对你所处环境的一种正常或可以理解的反应。很多时候，他们
that you're coming out of. And a lot of times they miss problems in the home and the environment, which, you know, they're in the ER, they don't have time to play detective. But if you, that doctor is required in order to get paid and to use your insurance so that you don't have this bill to give you a diagnosis, and that's the best one they can come up with in the 30 minutes while you're there. If they weren't required to do that, if that was a system that was rethought I mean a lot of those providers probably don't want to have to do that anyway
对你所处环境的正常或可以理解的反应。很多时候，他们忽略了家庭和环境中的问题，你知道，他们在急诊室，没有时间当侦探。但是，那位医生为了获得报酬并使用你的保险，以免你承担这笔账单，必须给你一个诊断，而这是他们在那里30分钟内能想到的最好的诊断。如果他们不需要这样做，如果这是一个被重新思考的系统，我的意思是，很多提供者可能根本不想这样做。
I mean we do the things in our job that we have to and when you make that one of them you're gonna continue to Get that result even if the provider is good and well-intentioned and understand these concepts and a lot of times when you talk to them They do And a lot of times when you talk to them, they do. James, you do a lot of the kind of mindfulness stuff and then brain spotting with more kind of executives and doctors. Can you explain some of the ways that you get to a place that is, I don't know,
我的意思是，我们在工作中做我们必须做的事情，当你把这变成其中之一时，你就会继续得到那个结果，即使提供者是好的、善意的并且理解这些概念。很多时候当你和他们交谈时，他们确实理解。詹姆斯，你做了很多正念方面的工作，然后用脑点疗法（Brainspotting）处理更多的高管和医生。你能解释一下你达到某种状态的一些方式吗，我不知道，
more of an energy or a subjective realm that doesn't quite fit into a number, but is the root of a lot of the effectiveness of some of those things? Well, first off, it's funny that and I don't know how this is going to be taken, but I get a lot of those that type of population coming in that kind of had said, you know, talk therapy just doesn't work for me. You know, I have not had success with talking.
更多的是一种能量或主观领域，它不太符合数字，但却是其中一些事物有效性的根源？好吧，首先，有趣的是，我不知道这会被如何看待，但我确实有很多那种类型的人群进来，他们说，你知道，谈话疗法对我不起作用。你知道，我在谈话方面没有取得成功。
And it's like, well, what is talk therapy to you? Because that could be a lot of things, you know, that's just a sounding board or and they're like, well, you know, it's kind of CBT. They try to make me rethink this and that. I get to a place where a lot of these, especially a lot of these high functioning, well, I guess high functioning is a weird term. People have this idea that I need something more, something actionable, something not necessarily physical, to kind of get me into this space that is very beneficial for myself. And you get to a point that they offer, I mean, you just go with the flow. It is, it is the person that is in front of you, again, that you are paying attention to, and not necessarily the cookbook of options to kind of you. I allow my individuals to kind of, again, not be the professional in what I provide, but professional of themselves. And
就像是，好吧，对你来说谈话疗法是什么？因为那可能有很多含义，你知道，那只是一个倾诉对象，或者他们说，好吧，你知道，那是认知行为疗法（CBT）。他们试图让我重新思考这个和那个。我达到了一种境界，很多这些人，尤其是很多这些高功能的人，好吧，我想高功能是一个奇怪的词。人们有这种想法，我需要更多的东西，一些可操作的东西，不一定是身体上的，来让我进入这个对我非常有益的空间。你达到了一点，他们提供，我的意思是，你只是顺其自然。它就是你面前的那个人，再次强调，你关注的是那个人，而不是一定要遵循某种选项手册。我允许我的个人，再次强调，不要成为我所提供服务中的专业人士，而是成为他们自己的专业人士。而
then they'll offer up some stuff. I'm like, That's it. That's what we're gonna go. We're gonna do Brainspotting. This would be perfect for you, and things like that. I've dived into a lot of shadow work recently because a lot of people are having, which is a very, you know, it's very woo-woo in the sense of like, no one wants to talk about what the shadow is. And that's happened naturally to a lot of my, a lot of the people that I've seen come through. Yeah, it's a collective. It's a thing happening in the collective. And, and it's people, and it's, that's where we're kind of coming back around to the field has kind of moved into like trauma trauma trauma and this is where the collective and the peanut gallery are kind of catching up and the language that they're that we're using that's more accessible to everybody is like is shadow work i mean that's a perfect you know and it
然后他们会提出一些东西。我说，就是这样。这就是我们要去的地方。我们要进行脑点疗法。这对你来说是完美的，诸如此类。我最近深入研究了阴影工作（shadow work），因为很多人都有，这非常，你知道，在某种意义上非常“玄学”，没有人想谈论阴影是什么。这在很多我见过的人身上自然而然地发生了。是的，这是一个集体现象。这是集体中正在发生的事情。而且，这是人们，这就是我们回到这个领域的地方，这个领域已经转向了创伤、创伤、创伤，这就是集体和旁观者正在赶上的地方，我们正在使用的语言对每个人来说都更容易理解，那就是阴影工作，我的意思是，这是一个完美的，你知道，它
does bring back in like the original like you know union um union terminology so makes, you know, it's basically like our patients are now showing up saying we want to do that. We're here to do the work is what that means to me. You know? Yeah. That's what I was trying to talk about when I was like, not physical. They just, they want to do something.
确实带回了像最初的荣格术语，所以，你知道，这基本上就像我们的病人现在出现并说我们想做那个。对我来说，这意味着我们在这里做这项工作。你知道吗？是的。这就是我试图谈论的，当我说是非身体的时候。他们只是，他们想做点什么。
Yeah. Yeah. I think what you're talking about, James, is the ability of the intellect to avoid emotion that a lot of times, I mean, because I've had very skilled talk therapists that were really able to stop me from being able to deflect and entertain and like push me into the thing that I'm avoiding feeling. But to my, my experience with therapy, I mean, that's what works. And brain spotting does that pretty quickly, in a way that we may not even really fully understand how it works, but it's
是的。是的。我认为你所谈论的，詹姆斯，是智力回避情绪的能力，很多时候，我的意思是，因为我遇到过非常熟练的谈话治疗师，他们真的能够阻止我进行防御和娱乐，并推动我进入我正在回避感受的事情。但对我来说，我对治疗的体验，我的意思是，这就是有效的。而脑点疗法很快就能做到这一点，以一种我们甚至可能没有完全理解它是如何工作的方式，但它是
reproducible. And we know that it does. But, you know, one of the reasons why on this podcast, like I like to sit with the kind of kind of crazy, new age, woo, concepts, and also, you know, a lot of these kind of like Eastern wisdom traditions and perennial philosophy, and then also state of the art neuro neuroscience is that when you when you do that, I think there is kind of a synthesis in how a lot of these things are saying the same thing, like something like shadow work, like you're talking about, which is, you know, Jungian. Yeah, there's a lot of mysticism and things that people
可复制的。我们知道它确实有效。但是，你知道，为什么在这个播客上，我喜欢坐下来讨论那些有点疯狂的、新时代的、玄学的概念，还有，你知道，很多这些东方智慧传统和永恒哲学，以及最先进的神经科学，原因在于当你这样做时，我认为在这些事物如何表达同一件事方面有一种综合，比如像你谈论的阴影工作，也就是荣格的。是的，有很多神秘主义和人们
may want to discount because it scares them or they're not familiar with those concepts if you crack those books. But look at what it's saying. It's saying that there are huge emotional reactions that you avoid, feeling those implicit emotions. I don't want to feel trapped. I don't want to feel out of control. Or that you're enmeshed with, that you feel all the time, I have to be disangry. I have to be disaware.
可能因为害怕或不熟悉这些概念而想要忽略的东西，如果你去读那些书的话。但看看它在说什么。它说有巨大的情绪反应是你回避的，感受那些隐含的情绪。我不想感到被困住。我不想感到失去控制。或者你与之纠缠在一起的，你一直感觉到的，我必须不生气。我必须不觉察。
I have to understand how everything works or else I'm not safe. And that going into the shadow in a Jungian sense is challenging your relationship to those things. What if you can go back and feel that without dying? What if you can let go of this and you can still be okay and you can still feel safety without anger? I mean, that's shadow work and polyvagal theory and a whole lot of the interesting work that people like Gazaniga and Demacio and many, many more are doing are noticing those same things in neurology and cognitive sciences in a way that those professions seem to be comfortable with. And for some reason,
我必须了解一切是如何运作的，否则我就不安全。而以荣格的方式进入阴影是在挑战你与这些事物的关系。如果你能回去感受它而不死呢？如果你能放下这个，你仍然可以很好，你仍然可以在没有愤怒的情况下感到安全呢？我的意思是，那是阴影工作和多迷走神经理论，以及像加扎尼加（Gazaniga）和达马西奥（Damasio）等许多人正在做的许多有趣的工作，都在神经学和认知科学中注意到了同样的事情，以一种这些专业似乎感到舒适的方式。而且出于某种原因，
academic psychology is less comfortable with them than neurology and cognitive science. I mean, I don't know. I mean, Haley, you work with women and mothers a lot. Do you see places where that their experience or the factors that are influencing them just don't fit perfectly into a diagnosis or sort of clash with the randomized controlled trial model for figuring out how to help? I mean, yeah, just short answer. Yeah. I think my experience with that really, a lot of that is, again, research or model, a lot of models or interventions are top down, and that's what's being used.
学术心理学比神经学和认知科学对它们更不适应。我的意思是，我不知道。我的意思是，海莉，你经常与女性和母亲一起工作。你是否看到她们的经历或影响她们的因素并不完全符合诊断，或者与用于弄清楚如何提供帮助的随机对照试验模型相冲突的地方？我的意思是，是的，简短的回答。是的。我认为我对此的体验真的，很多都是，再次强调，研究或模型，很多模型或干预措施是自上而下的，这就是正在使用的。
Again, birth has now become hypermedicalized, and so again, we're throwing back kind of into that medical model. But yeah, I think there is a huge disparity around women not being able to have a voice or share their experiences or know what, you know, they just have these expectations of, oh, well, this is just what I'm supposed to do because this is what everybody else has done or what my mom told me would happen versus like what the actual experience was. So I think there's just such a disconnect, particularly around birthing, but even more, just because you're forced to wanna fit into this medical model that it doesn't work because it's a very intense, it is a traumatic experience.
再次强调，分娩现在已经变得高度医疗化，所以我们又回到了那种医疗模式。但是是的，我认为在女性无法拥有发言权或分享她们的经历或知道什么方面存在巨大的差异，你知道，她们只是有这种期望，哦，好吧，这只是我应该做的，因为这是其他人所做的，或者我妈妈告诉我会发生什么，而不是实际的体验是什么。所以我认为存在着巨大的脱节，特别是在分娩方面，甚至更多，仅仅因为你被迫想要适应这种医疗模式，它不起作用，因为它是一种非常强烈的、创伤性的体验。
It's a life-changing experience. And again, check boxes don't you can't quantify that. And I think women have a hard time. There's that expectation to be like, How was your birth? How did it go? Did it do do do you know, and women can't even verbalize that it's like, Oh, because it's not that way for them. And so even just holding space for women to be able to have those opportunities is really important. I found that is such a critical piece, like doing all of this, doing research. What I studied, my PhD, is we have
这是一种改变人生的经历。再次强调，复选框不能，你无法量化这一点。我认为女性很难。有一种期望是，你的分娩怎么样？进展如何？你做了这个那个，你知道，女性甚至无法表达出来，就像，哦，因为对她们来说不是那样的。所以即使只是为女性提供空间让她们能够有这些机会也是非常重要的。我发现这是一个如此关键的部分，就像做所有这些，做研究。我研究的，我的博士学位，是我们有
a lot of quantitative data. We don't really know what women are experiencing. And for me, that's a really important place to start. Instead of assuming that we know or doctors know what's best for women. And are you saying there, Haley, that a lot of times we're not maybe aware of our emotional experience
很多定量数据。我们并不真正知道女性正在经历什么。对我来说，这是一个非常重要的起点。而不是假设我们知道或医生知道什么对女性最好。海莉，你是在说，很多时候我们可能没有意识到我们的情感体验
or the way that our environment's affecting us. So even if we do the screener in the hospital and we check for traumatic birth or we check for something, we still, you know, maybe you're missing something because we haven't made room to consider kind of a deeper embodied or I don't want to speak for you. But yeah. I'll just share my own personal experience of like, when you get one six week postpartum checkup and they give you the depression form, they don't really talk about it, it's just like in your paperwork.
或者环境影响我们的方式吗？所以即使我们在医院做了筛查，检查了创伤性分娩或检查了某些东西，我们仍然，你知道，可能错过了某些东西，因为我们没有留出空间来考虑一种更深层的具身化，或者我不想替你说话。但是是的。我只想分享我自己的个人体验，比如，当你进行一次六周的产后检查，他们给你抑郁症表格时，他们并没有真正谈论它，它只是在你的文书工作中。
And even as someone who I felt like I advocated for myself, I was so embarrassed that I was experiencing like postpartum depression that I just kind of, I don't know, I try to mark things a little bit higher because I didn't want to bring it up with my doctor. But then she was just flipping through and was like, oh, it looks like you're good. No depression.
即使作为一个我觉得我为自己辩护的人，我也因为经历产后抑郁症而感到非常尴尬，以至于我只是，我不知道，我试着把分数标记得高一点，因为我不想和我的医生提起。但后来她只是翻阅了一下，说，哦，看起来你很好。没有抑郁症。
And I was just on the verge of having a complete breakdown. There is just no space for that. There is very little room to be able to hold space and to feel safe. Safety is a huge thing. Safety is a huge thing and I think there's very little space within those, you know, you see your doctor once six weeks postpartum and that's it. To be able to, you know, address a lot of things that are still going on physically, emotionally, mentally, spiritually,
而我当时正处于彻底崩溃的边缘。根本没有空间。几乎没有空间来容纳空间和感到安全。安全感是一件大事。安全感是一件大事，我认为在这些里面几乎没有空间，你知道，你产后六周看一次医生，就这样了。能够，你知道，解决很多在身体上、情感上、心理上、精神上仍然在发生的事情，
that are, they're getting missed. Yeah. Well, I think we're coming to the end of our episode. Is there anybody that has, you know, anything else that feels like a good place to share something before we end that we don't get to? I don't have anything, but we could spend forever talking about birth. I'm just like holding my tongue out here.
那些被错过的。是的。好吧，我想我们快要结束这一期节目了。还有人有，你知道，其他任何觉得在结束之前分享一些我们没有涉及到的东西的好地方吗？我没有什么，但我们可以花永远的时间谈论分娩。我只是在这里咬着舌头。
We can talk about. Yeah, I'm sure we will again. Attachment and birth and everything. Yeah, I think, you know, for me, one of the things that I'd like to see is separate, you know, how something works from does it work? And to see is it reproducible first and then figure out all of the different smushier variables about those things and then you know as a pathway to that maybe make room for things that are just self-evidencing that we just say we know these things are
我们可以谈论。是的，我相信我们还会再谈的。依恋和分娩以及所有的一切。是的，我想，你知道，对我来说，我希望看到的一件事是分开，你知道，某样东西是如何运作的与它是否有效？先看看它是否可复制，然后再弄清楚关于这些事情的所有不同的模糊变量，然后你知道，作为通往这一点的路径，也许为那些只是自我证明的事情留出空间，我们只是说我们知道这些事情是
true even though maybe they're not directly provable in a way that would let semantic psychology and other things be more a part of medicine than they are. Well, I appreciate you guys getting on today and we will see you next week. Alrighty. Hey guys, I wanted to pop in here to give you a quick reminder that we do this podcast for free and there are significant expenses associated with it, including the biggest resource in my life right now, which is time. One of the things that would really help us, and hopefully would help you, would be to check out
真实的，即使也许它们在某种程度上不能直接证明，这会让语义心理学和其他事物比现在更多地成为医学的一部分。好吧，我很感谢你们今天加入，我们下周见。好的。嘿，伙计们，我想插一句，提醒你们一下，我们免费制作这个播客，并且有相关的重大开支，包括我现在生活中最大的资源，那就是时间。能真正帮助我们，也希望对你们有帮助的一件事，就是去看看
one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. Hardy is a vitamin company that I never encountered the advertising of. We heard over and over again from multiple people with treatment resistant anxiety and dopamine disorders like bipolar disorder and other things that they had tried everything and Hardy was what worked. And so I checked them out and they have really good research. I'm not a fan of a lot of the BS that's in the supplement and wellness space. Um, Hardy paid for a lot of research on their product. And when I ordered some for myself, I saw a big difference in my life. And my wife made fun of me, thought it was going to be Alex Jones selling vitamins on the radio and when she tried them she really liked them too.
我们的赞助商之一，Hardy Nutritionals。Hardy是一家我从未见过其广告的维生素公司。我们一次又一次地从多个患有难治性焦虑症和多巴胺障碍（如双相情感障碍和其他疾病）的人那里听说，他们尝试了一切，而Hardy是有效的。所以我去看了看，他们确实有很好的研究。我不喜欢补充剂和健康领域中很多胡说八道的东西。嗯，Hardy为他们的产品支付了很多研究费用。当我为自己订购了一些时，我看到了我生活中巨大的差异。我妻子取笑我，以为这会是亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）在广播里卖维生素，当她尝试了之后，她也非常喜欢它们。
There's a lot of data about how they can reduce the symptoms of ADHD without medications or lower your need for medication also manage some of the effects of autism spectrum disorder and a whole lot of other things. A newer research around nutrition is saying that the synergistic effects of multiple things being planned to work together, uh, is a lot more effective than one thing working alone. You can get a lot of information about that on our website. Um, or you can head over to get Hardy. That's G E T H A R D Y and use offer code taproot for 15% off. It would help them. It would help me.
有很多关于它们如何在不使用药物的情况下减少多动症症状或降低你对药物需求的数据，也可以管理一些自闭症谱系障碍的影响以及其他很多事情。关于营养的较新研究表明，多种事物协同作用的协同效应，嗯，比单一事物单独作用要有效得多。你可以在我们的网站上获得很多关于这方面的信息。嗯，或者你可以前往get Hardy。那是G E T H A R D Y，并使用优惠码taproot可享受15%的折扣。这会帮助他们。这会帮助我。
And it also would probably help you. One of the more frequent things that patients and people in the randomized controlled trials that Hardy conducted report is that they feel more themself, more focused and more effective at getting things done, which can result in all of us having a little bit more time. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且它可能也会帮助你。Hardy进行的随机对照试验中的病人和人们报告的最常见的事情之一是，他们感到更像自己，更专注，更有效地完成事情，这可以导致我们所有人多出一点时间。你 这里还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。